je vous propose que nous démarrions
monsieur le Président l'Association des
maires de France et sur la route
il ne saurait tarder mais notre
programme étant intense et conséquent
dans le respect des agendas de chacun je
propose que nous démarrions je vous
remercie d'être aussi nombreux sur ce
sujet qui est une véritable oeuvre
collective d'affirmation
d'intention mais aussi de vouloir
remercier à vous et je voudrais
excuser le président du Sénat Gérard
archi qui comme vous le savez
assure aujourd'hui on fait ce matin la
présidence d'une séquence importante qui
est consacrée aux retraites et qui nous
rejoindra en fin de matinée que Monsieur
le Ministre BECHU qui représentera
madame borne que nous entendons en visio
mais qui avaient un rendez-vous
international donc
Mesdames et Messieurs les représ
d'associations des lieux monsieur le
Président de la NCT madame la Présidente
du CM1 madame la secrétaire général du
gouvernement monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président de la délégation
collectivités à des centralisation chez
rémytroux Monsieur d'Arnaud qui est
président de la délégation prospective
et qui est en quelque sorte très souvent
mon binôme sur tous les sujets de
collectivités Mesdames et Messieurs les
intervenants mesdames et messieurs donc
ils me revient donc d'ouvrir ces états
généraux et nous aurons je l'ai dit le
plaisir de l'accueillir enfin en fin de
journal ces étages généraux les États
généraux sont parfois semblent-ils un
mot un peu ambitieux mais je crois que
notre détermination collective doit être
ambitieux parce que nous pour qui vont
un triple un triple objectif le premier
qui sera débattu au cours de la de la
première table ronde qui est le recueil
des témoignages de terrain le Sénat à
cœur de nourrir sa manière sa façon de
légiférer à partir de la réalité des
choses et l'écoute du terrain est
extrêmement importante et c'est pour ça
que très souvent nous procédons au-delà
de on va dire de nos expériences
personnelles de nos rencontres dans nos
circonscriptions nous procédons très
souvent à des consultations des lieux et
mes points de rentrer en parlera tout à
l'heure il se trouve personne ici et
surpris que la norme est en haut de
toutes les préoccupations de tous les
élus quel qu'il soit donc c'est un sujet
à la fois récurrent mais qu'il est
important de prendre en compte je crois
parce qu'aujourd'hui
la surenchère de la norme a des vacances
notamment financières considérable à un
moment où l'argent public est rare à un
moment où nous avons à faire face à des
dépenses supplémentaires il est plus que
jamais
nécessaire et salutaire d'optimiser
l'argent public et d'avoir une dépense
qui soit juste et pertinente et qu'il
faut se désengager de ce corset de la
norme pour pouvoir non seulement agir
mais encore une fois
optimiser optimiser la dépense publique
parce que la norme qui est qui est
nécessaire et
utile quand elle devient en quelque
sorte obèse la norme non seulement
ralentie les projets mais parfois
empêchent même la réalisation d'un
certain nombre de projets au service de
nos concitoyens alors deux chiffres sur
le coût de l'inflation normative des
chiffres sérieux le premier venant de la
DGCL qu'évalue après de 2 milliards le
coût total pour les collectivités de
cette inflation normative entre 2017 et
2021 mais le dernier rapport d'activité
du cneen dont je salue les 1000 ans
présidents Alain Lambert qui ne peut
être l'un mais qui est aujourd'hui
représenté par notre collègue Arnaud
Bazin le CNN disait-je évalue à 2
milliards 500 millions d'euros
naturellement pour la seule année 2022
le coup des normes ceux qui veut dire
30% de plus que le total cumulé du
quinquennat
2017-2021 donc nous frôlons le vertige
si nous ne l'avons pas dépassé et
peut-être nous dit-on que ces derniers
chiffres pour être sous-évalués puisque
le CNN lui-même nous dit cette fondée
sur les évaluations fournies par les
gouvernements et je ne vais pas ici en
doute la vérité des chiffres du le
gouvernement mais ce sont des
évaluations qui ont été fournies au fil
de l'eau à partir des fiches d'impact le
deuxième objectif dont nous souhaitons
parler aujourd'hui c'est l'exploration
de solutions simplification jusqu'à ce
qu'avec mon collèguerémyreau nous ne
nous sommes pas intéressés au stock je
n'ose pas dire que
aller
alléger le stock est un combat donc qui
Chota ce que peut-être et que peut-être
est-il le plus utile de s'intéresser à
l'évitement
de la surenchère de normes et donc nous
nous sommes tournés un peu vers l'avenir
en voulant de manière très simple sans
bouger les textes et sans rajouter des
normes en essayant de définir un process
de fabrique de la loi qui soit plus
vertueux si je veux dire mais en tout
cas plus rigoureux et qui about un
résultat plus pertinent c'est donc le
thème de la deuxième table ronde puisque
là nous avons exploré nous proposerons
des solutions qui sont simplifications
pleine de bon sens et j'ai je pense
souvent à la manière dont les élus
locaux et notamment les maires procèdent
à la mise en oeuvre d'un projet et ils
font de l'étude d'impact comme Monsieur
Jourdain faisait de la prose sans le
savoir parce qu'ils essaient de mesurer
avant de prendre une décision et de la
mettre en oeuvre les différentes
conséquences qu'il pourrait y avoir et
les effets collatéraux d'une décision et
donc nous nous proposons
en quelque sorte une méthode de
collective pour remédier à cette
prolifération normative donc l'idée
c'est de se discipliner
d'être chacun d'entre nous empreintes de
plus de rigueur pour essayer d'É ce que
j'appelle des accidents industriels de
de la norme le troisième objectif
qui est particulièrement
intéressant et remarquable et qui
souligne sans doute la prise de
conscience collective d'une
urgence et d'une impérieuse nécessaire
c'est que enfin de à la fin de ses
colloques nous allons
procéder à la signature d'une charte
d'engagement cette charte d'engagement
sera signée cossigné par le président du
Sénat au nom du Sénat et par le
gouvernement monsieur Béchu sera ici le
représentant du gouvernement et nous
serons naturellement largement soutenus
et conforté par le CNN et parce que nous
pensons que dire c'est bien mais que
faire c'est mieux nous avons souhaité
que ces colocs que ce colloque ne soit
pas que de la parole mais qu'il nous
engage collectivement parce que je crois
que retrouver la confiance de nos
concitoyens par une réelle efficacité de
l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre nous oblige tous parce que je
pense que la situation
est grave et parfois nous avons même
dépassé le stade de la gravité qui
l'emporte que la fabrique de la norme et
de la loi portée réalisée par tous les
acteurs conduisent une véritable
efficacité et en tout cas une pertinence
qui soit je dirais bien doser le mal est
connu on est capable de l'identifier les
causes en sont connues elles sont
multiples je crois qu'il est difficile
de faire son norme puisqu'il y a une
complexité des sujets ici nous devons
prendre en compte de très belles
intentions des objectifs
environnementaux des objectifs
sanitaires des objectifs d'égalité des
droits et qu'à un moment ces grandes
intentions quand elles se croisent elle
fabrique elle fabrique de la complexité
et à cela il faut ajouter un principe de
précaution qui aujourd'hui inscrit dans
la Constitution et qui doit se conjuguer
avec la judiciarisation qui augmente je
donnerai un seul exemple aujourd'hui
quelques mains ont interpellé la
ministre madame Faure pour demander s'il
ne pouvait pas y avoir une norme
nationale sur l'amplitude de l'éclairage
public puisque aujourd'hui les élus
étant amenés pour des raisons
économiques à diminuer l'éclairage
public certains font face à des
complaintes de leurs concitoyens qui
disent mais Monsieur ou Madame le Maire
nous avons un risque d'insécurité donc
je pense que je vois madame Jaro qui me
dit qu'à mon selimine elle a vécu donc
nous nous voyons où nous conduisent où
nous conduisent ces abus donc cette
charte d'engagement est IMPAC te de
confiance et de responsabilité que nous
signons avec beaucoup de volonté de
détermination et beaucoup d'humilité
parce que je pense que le miracle
absolue ne se produira pas demain mais
je pense que cette charte d'engagement
nous oblige et qu'en tout cas elle
résonne comme un rappel à l'ordre au fur
et à mesure de l'avancée de nos travaux
et conforme n'est-ce pas cher Rémi à nos
engagements de nous évaluons
la réalisation de cette charte
d'engagement nous vous le promettons et
nous vous le devons donc au Sénat nous
pensons que il faut vraiment que nous
arrivions un changement de culture et de
pratique et à penser que l'efficacité ne
vient pas de la norme et qu'elle vient
de la confiance dans les élus locaux de
l'intelligence des territoires de la
nécessité de s'adapter et c'est bien à
une nouvelle culture de la norme qu'il
faut nous être les je pense que nous
pouvons guérir en tout cas il faut avoir
le souhait et entreprendre un traitement
de choc et je crois que c'est autour de
trois principes que nous construirons
une meilleure loi la subsidiarité la
sobriété et la confiance je vous
remercie et Monsieur Lisnard va sans
doute nous rejoindre voilà en attendant
nous allons démarrer la première table
ronde
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame Gatel mesdames messieurs
bonjour Xavier Brivet rédacteur en chef
de maire de France j'ai en charge
l'animation de cette matinée qui se
déroulera en deux temps deux tables
rondes la première consacrée à des
témoignages d'élus locaux et de juristes
sur l'impact des normes sur la gestion
publique locale avec des exemples très
concrets et la seconde table ronde à
partir de 11h30 sur les propositions du
Sénat que de la délégation que Madame
Gatel nous synthétisera que nous
mettrons en débat avec des juristes des
membres du cnen le Conseil d'État et un
professeur de droit public voilà pour la
matinée
à l'issue de cette seconde table ronde
aura lieu un discours de Christophe
Béchu le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires un discours de clôture du
président du Sénat et Madame Gatel vient
de le dire la signature de la charte
d'engagement du gouvernement et du Sénat
engagement en faveur de la
simplification des concernant les
collectivités locales voilà donc une
matinée assez conséquente nous devions
avoir un propos introductif là de du
président de l'AMF David Lisnard et
maire de Cannes il arrive dans quelques
minutes pour ne pas prendre de retard je
vais passer la parole à Monsieur Rémi
Pointreau c'est notaire du Cher et
vice-président de la délégation aux
collectivités locales et à la
décentralisation du Sénat chargé de la
simplification des normes monsieur
Pointreau vous allez nous livrer les
chiffres clés de la consultation que le
Sénat avait organisé auprès des élus
locaux sur leur ressenti par rapport aux
normes ou nous présenter les principaux
résultats de cette consultation et puis
ensuite si le président l'isnard est là
nous lui donnons la parole et sinon nous
passerons au témoignage de trois élus
locaux je vous cède la parole merci
donc madame la Présidente chère
Françoise et mesdames messieurs en vous
grattes et qualités pour n'oublier
personne mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues
tout d'abord vous dire que nous avons
effectivement avec ma collègue Françoise
Gatel cossigné un rapport sur pour la
simplification des normes applicables
aux collectivités territoriales et il
porte essentiellement sur le processus
de la production de la norme et on aura
donc tout à l'heure un débat avec bien
sûr on a fait des propositions et des
solutions pour
éviter et diminuer ce nombre de normes
parallèlement on a fait donc une
consultation auprès des des élus locaux
avec pour objectif
d'abord d'évaluer des conséquences
négatives de l'inflation normative sur
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
locales et déterminer les champs de
l'action publique pour simplifier
à simplifier prioritairement alors je
vais essayer de vous présenter à moins
que monsieur le président l'isnard
prenne la parole maintenant je continue
donc je vais vous présenter les grandes
lignes des résultats de cette
consultation nous avons à peu près de
2000 élus qui ont répondu
donc on a finalement une très grande
majorité de répondants
92% qui sont des élus locaux et parmi
eux plus de la moitié appartiennent à
des communes de moins de 1000 habitants
les élus
sont environ 80% à ressentir une
aggravation de la situation depuis les
élections municipales de 2020 il faut le
souligner et je vous j'ajoute que
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est une des
causes mais on a une
un nombre de démissions plus en plus
importantes dans nos dans nos communes
et c'est assez préoccupant
dans notre rapport nous soulignons par
exemple que le code général des
collectivités territoriales à triplés de
volume en 20 ans vous pouvez peut-être
le madame de Munk le mettre en avant
puisque il dépasse aujourd'hui le
million de mots
certains élus par même de d'addiction de
la norme ou d'harcèlement textuel
d'ailleurs nous avons hésité à en faire
le titre de notre rapport on n'a pas osé
ensuite cette cette complexité
en plus d'être source d'incertitude et
d'incompréhension à entraîner des
conséquences négatives pour les projets
locaux pour
82% des répondants
et effectivement
on constate sur la
diapo numéro 5 que la complexité et la
multiplication des normes entraîne en
effet la modification
parfois le report parfois l'abandon des
projets
qui est porté par les collectivités
quand on ajoute à cela l'inflation que
nous vivons vous voyez que ça fait
beaucoup de dégâts en termes
d'investissement pour nos communes
et ça engendre évidemment un coup
important supplémentaire pour nos
collectivités
je signale d'ailleurs que le lancement
d'une mission d'information portant
notamment sur l'impact des normes sur
l'équilibre des finances locales son
président est Jérôme Bacher je sais pas
s'il est s'il est présent il devait nous
rejoindre dès la reporter Ghislaine
Pentel qui a donc commencé à estimer le
coût des normes qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure par notre présidente
alors en plus de peser sur les projets
locaux
les normes imposées aux collectivités
sont souvent jugés contradictoires
par les élus et ce qui complexifie
sensiblement leur mise en oeuvre voyez
les les chiffres qui sont devant vous
c'est le cas par exemple du
Zéro artificialisation nette les
fameuses ânes
dont nous dépatons nous allons débattre
encore ce soir au Sénat puisque on a
prévu un texte pour améliorer pas le
texte précédent le décret qui était qui
est sorti de du texte que nous avions
voté et qui ne correspond pas
à ce que nous avons voté dans nos
parlements que ce soit l'assemblée au
Sénat donc il y a quand même un vrai
sujet là
et ces fameux ânes donc c'est Lucas
typique ou on a des nos élus sont
coincés entre les injonctions à bâtir
par exemple notamment des logements
sociaux et une contrainte assez brutale
de non-artificialisation
et puis des pouvoirs publics doivent
aussi bâtir
déséquilibre toujours plus subtil plus
complexe qu'on nous impose jamais
pleinement satisfaisant d'ailleurs entre
les demandes toujours
peuvent parfois je vais dire légitime
qui sont pris séparément mais souvent
contradictoires et globalement bloquant
pour le développement de nos territoires
et je crois que nous avons bien sûr sur
le ce problème de norme je le dis très
sincèrement nous avons une
responsabilité collective et nous
parlementaire compris parce que bon on a
tendance parfois à peut-être trop avant
délai de texte à être trop précis sur
les sur les textes et ces normes sont de
plus en plus techniques et tellement
précis que ça ça bloque le système et ça
nécessite de disposer parfois une
expertise juridique dont souvent les
collectivités notamment les plus petites
ne disposent pas
dès lors l'accompagnement de l'État
représente une forte attente des
collectivités et pourtant aujourd'hui on
constate que les les nausées à 75% que
elles sont insuffisantes
alors non seulement
l'accompagnement de l'État est jugé
insuffisant face à la complexité des
normes mais le phénomène est accentué
par des interprétations variables alors
selon le service
où l'agent qui veut respecter à la norme
par le reprenait mais presque et parfois
entre départements parce qu'on voit bien
que entre chaque département il y a des
différents associations de
d'interprétation et ça c'est un vrai
sujet
quand on a les mêmes problématiques on
s'aperçoit que le département d'un côté
n'applique pas les normes de la même
façon et c'est ce que déplore 75% des
répondants
et on constate que cette
situation est surtout source de
d'insécurité juridique
je rappelle aussi que à mon initiative à
l'initiative de la délégation on a ainsi
le Sénat institué lors de l'examen de
l'approche du projet de loi 3DS une
conférence de dialogue état collectivité
et cette conférence était placée auprès
du préfet malheureusement cette
disposition
disparue du texte définitif et donc
Mathieu d'Arnaud à pauvre de la tête
pour approuver malheureusement ce qui
était décidé je regrette et car une
telle instance permettrait à tous les
acteurs locaux et lui au fonctionnaires
de devrait pour améliorer énormément
applicable collectivités locales
d'ailleurs il y avait un pouvoir de
dérogation qui a été accordé au préfet
également et qui est peu qui est peu
finalement appliqué tout simplement par
crainte de cette
judiciarisation que nous subissons
crainte aussi parfois de la notation que
peuvent aussi avoir les préfets en
fonction de leur décision
et puis on ajoute à cela le principe de
précaution qui a été mise en la
Constitution qui rajoute et qui est un
facteur inflationniste de normes
alors
pour améliorer
ces normes applicables collectivités
territoriales
ça fournit au préfet l'occasion de faire
remonter à l'administration centrale les
difficultés
identifier localement mais c'est suffit
pas de les faire remonter faut que après
on puisse avoir des des solutions un
autre intérêt de ce dispositif serait
d'améliorer également sur le terrain
l'application des normes et politiques
publiques en formalisant une parole
unique de l'État parce que là aussi on a
parfois des paroles qui sont assez
diversifiées et en effet très nombreux
sont des élus qui déplorent les normes
ou injonctions contradictoires de la
part de différentes administrations de
l'État
on constate que finalement l'emballement
normatif tient également à une croyance
quasi mystique de la norme
d'ailleurs c'est un mâle très français
quand ils veulent répondre
à une émotion ou qu'il manque de moyens
financiers les pouvoirs publics cèdent
souvent volontiers à la création magique
de la norme en donnant l'illusion
l'illusion qu'ils ont réglé de problème
sur
un autre sujet
le secteur souffre particulièrement ses
complexité sur l'urbanisme je crois que
c'est le
50% des répondants en font un secteur
prioritaire
puisque ça devrait faire l'objet d'une
stratégie de simplification
on l'a fait au Sénat on a conduit de
nombreux travaux sur la simplification
du droit d'urbanisme avec mon collègue
François Calvet et magdonis au moment de
d'un texte sur l'urbanisme et on voit
bien que c'est un chantier qui reste
évidemment immense
d'autres domaines ont également été
identifiés dans la consultation ce soit
la répartition des compétences la
commande publique l'assainissement ou
encore l'environnement et les finances
publiques on voit bien que ça c'est des
sujets aussi mais l'urbanisme c'est
vraiment le sujet priorité
cette consultation a été aussi
l'occasion pour les élus de faire-part
de leur ressentir et de leur inquiétudes
vous avez les paroles d'élus mais vous
pourrez peut-être les entendre tout à
l'heure monsieur Brivet je crois bien
petite séquence
là-dessus chez énorme aujourd'hui si
complexe je l'ai dit déjà décourage des
élus locaux qui déplorent que faute de
connaissances
suffisante se retrouver régulièrement en
situation d'illégalité c'est ça la
problématique aujourd'hui et je vous
laisse bien sûr lire à l'écran quelque
parole d'élus qui illustrent
particulièrement le ras-le-bol de le de
nos élus
enfin
face à ce constat
les répondants ont été forces de
proposition afin de dégager des pistes
de réflexion et ces réponses ici sont
retranscrites sous forme de de nuage de
mots comme on le voit souvent maintenant
en termes de communication
certains points ont été
cités en termes d'amélioration la
formation en priorité qui s'impose comme
la première préoccupation des élus tant
pour eux-mêmes d'ailleurs que pour leurs
agents parce que nos agents sont aussi
confrontés à toutes ces problématiques
de nombreuses propositions étaient
formulées pour renforce renforcer
l'accompagnement de l'État et la
consommation la communication à
destination des collectivités et une
grande partie des répondants a également
mis en avant la nécessité d'une
meilleure prise en compte des
spécificités on parle beaucoup de
différenciation et ça c'est un sujet
majeur
on peut pas appliquer une règle partout
dans notre territoire il y a des
territoires où les règles pourraient
être différenciées dans des communes
rurales dans des territoires spécifiques
des zones de montagne des
territoires hyper ruraux où on peut pas
appliquer la norme de la même façon que
le milieu urbain enfin ou dans des
grandes agglomérations je crois que
c'est une des principales demandes et
puis aussi une meilleure adaptation des
études d'impact au contexte local c'est
vrai qu'on a des études d'impact qui
sont souvent très peu
travaillés on les propose d'ailleurs on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure au
CNE quelques jours avant de les étudier
les études d'impact qui sont pas
forcément objectifs
moi je voudrais pour conclure simplement
citer le président Pompidou
il y a 50 ans
avait dit
arrêtez d'emmerder les Français
arrêtez d'emmerder les Français je vais
dire arrêter d'emmerder les nos élus
territoriaux locaux et on s'aperçoit
depuis 50 ans on n'a pas arrêté de
complexifier
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment une thérapie de choc des
solutions concrètes pour casser cette
machine infernale de production des
normes merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur Cointreau pour cet état
des lieux qui plantent le décor la
parole aux élus locaux maintenant et
tout d'abord au premier d'entre eux si
j'ose dire David Lisnard maire de Cannes
président de l'Association des maires de
France pour un propos introductif
Monsieur listenard Vous dénoncez très
régulièrement depuis plusieurs années la
boulimie normative et réglementaire nous
vous écoutons et après nous basculons
sur les témoignages d'autres élus vous
avez la parole merci merci beaucoup je
vais en fait rebondir sur sur la
présentation qui vient qui vient d'être
faite plutôt que de vous lire un propos
en essayant de placer effectivement les
quelques-unes des convictions que avec
d'autres nous essayons de de faire
partager
mais en adressant à vous ici
je prêche des convaincus c'est toujours
le le biais l'artefact dans lequel on
est vous savez c'est le syndrome du curé
qui pendant son homélie aurait été plus
personne n'aille à la messe mais il le
dit au dernier
pourquoi vous dites ça parce que
la problématique de la simplification
versus la complication
est aussi ancienne que mon engagement
qui est chaque jour plus de réalité et
que malgré tout ce qui a pu être dit
pendant des années on a effectivement
cette croissance des normes et des
règles et que ce qui nous paraît ici
évident et parfois redondant dans nos
discours et en fait un objet qui est
hors du champ politique médiatique et
qu'il est très difficile de transmettre
ce matin publié une chronique comme tous
les 15 jours dans un quotidien qui
s'appelle l'opinion où je raconte mon
récit pour arriver à réutiliser les eaux
usées tout ce que je dis est vrai mais
encore en dessous de la réalité de ce
que j'affronte sur un projet qui était
pionnier il y a 10 ans premier en Europe
et qui va devenir dernier au moment où
j'arriverai à le faire voilà les
premiers seront les derniers on reste
dans la métaphore biblique pardonnez-moi
dans cette maison bien sûr marquée du
principe de laïcité je voulais vraiment
remercier le Sénat de son approche
toujours proactive sur ces questions et
au service des collectivités et des
communes de France et d'ailleurs plus
largement à travers son président Gérard
archer que je remercie de son écoute
permanente de son action permanente et
de son respect permanent à l'égard de
cette vieille maison qui est
l'Association des maires de France et
qui depuis 1907 elle a été depuis
reconnue l'utilité publique défend la
liberté locale
et c'est rien que de le dire fait du
bien défendre là où les libertés locales
comme matrice d'une certaine idée de
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics qui
génère de la prospérité de l'efficacité
de la démocratie la liberté locale les
libertés locales sont au cœur d'un
modèle républicain qui n'est pas
antinomique avec celui d'unité de la
nation c'est ce que je vais essayer
aussi rapidement d'esquisser je veux
vraiment saluer le travail inlassable de
Françoise Gatel la présidente de cette
délégation et bien sûr de son
vice-président Rémy pintro et d'avoir
pris cette initiative d'État généraux
d'État généraux
auxquels tout de suite vous avez associé
l'AMF et je vous enseignerai au nom de
toutes les communes de France et je
salue ici bien sûr les représentants de
toutes les communes de toutes les
associations elles sont ici sur des mers
ruraux et des petites villes de France
par des mois pour ceux que je
n'oublierai puisque je ne lirai pas donc
un papier face à moi mais en tout cas
voilà les communes de France sont
toujours associées à vos travaux et
notamment via la MF et ça je vous en
céglerai aussi
ce que je crois qu'il bien sûr les
constats il faut il faut toujours les
partager parce que ça apparaît virtuel
cette boulimie normative qui était
évoquée tout à l'heure dans ces
résultats de cette quête très
intéressant
elle est elle est quantifiable elle est
quantifiable et
le Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes qui a un rôle majeur en la
matière salut aussi le Conseil d'État
qui fait un travail permanent et
très précis sur ses problématiques là
elle est quantifiable pas toujours de
façon facile mais quand vous regardez
vous comptez le nombre de mots dans les
GIF France ou dans le Dalloz enfin je
vais pas citer de marque en particulier
mais vous constatez que le code de
l'environnement en disant et c'est un
chiffre facile à 10 ans 100000 un
million de mots voilà multiplier par 10
et que nulle est sensée ignorer la loi
que le code général des collectivités
territoriales le CGCT son volume a été
multiplié par trois en une quinzaine
d'années
et que nous sommes face à ces
injonctions contradictoires avec un
droit donc non seulement contradictoire
mais aussi superfétatoire et donc qui
multiplie les étapes obligatoires qui
tousse là sont des rimes pauvres
puisqu'elle nous appauvrissent
puisqu'elle multiplie les surcoûts et et
donc obstruction à l'action à l'action
publique le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes a évalué les
charges nets supplémentaires de textes
de 2022 à 2 milliards 500 000 euros pour
cette seule année
je rappelle que l'indexation de la DGF
qui serait en fait juste le maintien de
la DGF en neuroconstant c'est à dire en
fait le respect de la parole de l'État
que nous réclamons c'était 800 millions
d'euros n'a pas été suivi donc ce sont
des chiffres qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
avoir aussi à l'esprit que les
conséquences les enjeux de du combat qui
est le nôtre ne sont pas que financiers
ils sont évidemment financiers et c'est
au combien majeur dans un pays qui a le
record du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires à plus de 45% du PIB qui a
le record du monde absolu de la dépense
publique à 57% du PIB et qui
parallèlement voit une désertification
de service public en milieu rural mais
aussi en milieu urbain et donc ce
paradoxe inouï qui nous renvoie toujours
au président Pompidou et à son ouvrage
de nœud Gordien le nœud gordien qu'il
nous faut trancher aujourd'hui c'est
celui d'une surcharge d'une abondance de
dépenses publiques et d'une pénurie de
service public avec des fonctionnaires
très bien formés très honnêtes mais qui
paradoxalement dans le pays qui prélève
le plus ses dépenses le plus par rapport
à la richesse produite sont souvent en
dessous des normes de rémunération des
partenaires européens ce paradoxe fou ce
nœud gordien qu'il faut trancher c'est
celui précisément de la complication
complication qui à mon avis est le terme
le plus pertinent que complexification
car la complexité peut être un progrès
avoir des normes d'inclusion pour les
personnes porteuses de handicap des
normes de protection à des risques
incendies ou d'avoir des normes
d'hygiène alimentaire sont plutôt un
progrès social mais des et j'en
appellerai aussi à ça dans les solutions
à nous rapprocher aussi du secteur privé
qui est soumis aussi à cette
complication notamment les grandes
boîtes et qui lutte parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le choix que d'avoir des résultats
et bien face à cela il y a eu plusieurs
spécialistes
anglo-saxons qui estiment que lorsque il
y a une complexification
de 10% la complication et au moins de 50
%. c'est à dire que on va y répondre par
la création d'une Direction direction
qualité
direction des process qui va elle-même
générer ses propres contraintes et c'est
la spirale infernale de l'organe qui
crée la fonction et qui fait que on crée
des effets parasites de la création de
valeur pour multiplier les procédures
qui accompagnent la complexification et
qu'on complique plus que l'on
complexifie
l'excès de normes elle nuit donc non
seulement au finances publiques mais lui
aussi à nos libertés et je voudrais
vraiment insister là-dessus parce que
c'est un thème qui n'est pas toujours
évoqué et qui pourtant est majeur à nous
liberté puisque
la liberté c'est précisément de
maîtriser le droit qui est protecteur et
que seuls des spécialistes ou seuls des
collectivités pour rester dans ce qui
nous concerne plus directement qui ont
l'ingénierie juridique administrative
peuvent se sortir du maquis normatif et
on le voit très bien et dans les
communes rurales qui sont très souvent
privées d'accès à la politique publique
à cause des appels à projets à cause des
manifestations d'intérêt qui eux-mêmes
génèrent des process très lourds
et qui éloignent donc ceux qui sont
dépourvus du recours à un cabinet
conseil dont on a vu qu'il pouvait
atteindre des honoraires assez élevés
quand on fait l'agrégation nationale et
et qui voilà qui sont hors du champ
des communes des communautés de communes
rurales des communes des communes
rurales etc et donc et au niveau du
citoyen qui aujourd'hui enfin peut
prétendre connaître le droit quelle mère
peut prétendre connaître le droit mes
chers collègues ici nombreux présents y
compris venus de corse
lorsque le vous recevez
la réglementation thermique qui
s'applique à la construction des
bâtiments scolaires quelle est la
commune qui connaît les 1800 n'ont pas
mot mais page de cette réglementation
qui nous tombe dessus
enjeux donc de liberté
enjeu d'efficacité
en jeu tout simplement de civisme face
aux défis qui sont les autres
aujourd'hui je les cite des filles
climatiques des filles économiques etc
des fils sécuritaires
nous sommes nous subissons une crise
civique
qui se traduit par la violence faite aux
élus tu l'a évoqué tout à l'heure par
l'abstention par l'indifférence même à
la chose publique par l'invective sur
les réseaux sociaux ou qui est propre ou
sur des médias en flocon continue qui
est proportionnelle souvent à la vacuité
de la pensée et la complication le
caractère inaudible
inabordable des grandes règles qui
régissent la vie en société ne peut que
catalyser cette crise civique et de
surcroît comme elle est aussi cause
d'impuissance publique puisqu'elle
allonge les délais elle multiplie les
coûts elle fait renoncer à des projets
c'est impuissance publique conjuguée à
cette difficulté d'appréhender les
règles qui protègent
et qui émancipe et bien évidemment est
un facteur de crise civique donc de
crise de notre démocratie majeure donc
l'enjeu il est colossal il fait partie
des grands enjeux qui devraient être en
haut de l'agenda politique mais ici je
le répète je ne prêche que des
convaincus et je veux saluer d'ailleurs
le la pertinence du rapport Françoise
que vous avez sorti avec rémi.tro et qui
est vraiment extrêmement
utile alors bien sûr il y a eu des
initiatives
depuis que je suis petit j'ai envie de
dire
je fais la liste dans les éléments qui
m'ont été fournis depuis 1990 je vais
vous l'épargner mais régulièrement les
pouvoirs publics de bonne foi parce
qu'il y a toujours de la bonne foi font
des annonces de simplification et en
fait ce que l'on constate c'est que plus
on annonce de la simplification plus
c'est compliqué à la fin et je vais
essayer d'évoquer pourquoi parce que je
ce matin en prenant mon avion et en
subissant ma deuxième grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel de la semaine
si un jour vous voulez faire une
je sais pas s'il y a déjà eu des
rapports dans lequel je suis aiguilleurs
du ciel je suis prêt à porter mon
témoignage et
statut de fonctionnaire très bien payé
je crois que la Cour des comptes avait
sorti un rapport sur le nombre de jours
travaillés je ferme parenthèse mais très
compliqué d'être président des maires de
France quand vous n'êtes pas Parisien ce
qui est quand même un comble puisque par
définition
il y a
34954 chance de ne pas être parisien
quand vous êtes président de l'AMF
puisqu'il y a 34955 commune aujourd'hui
officiellement grâce au phénomène des
communes nouvelles qui ont été un vrai
phénomène de simplification
résultant d'une approche spontanée du
terrain et c'est là que je voulais en
venir et non pas d'une directive
verticale descendante
grâce à Françoise grâce à Jacques
paysard à tous ceux qui ont porté cela
et il y a quelques années
donc la démarche engagée aujourd'hui
elle a cela de pertinent qu'elle
s'attaque
aux causes
dont
que parfois nous chérissons malgré nous
tout en déplorant ses effets pour faire
une mauvaise retranscription de Bossuet
ce sont celles qui résultent du
conformisme de la production de la règle
vous savez vraiment arrondi disait
toujours je déteste autant le
conformisme et le révolutionnarisme
et on est en pleine dans la vie
politique nationale
actuelle le et les deux s'alimentent les
deux se nourrissent
c'est quoi le conformisme
conformisme qui renvoie au confort c'est
celui qui consiste à toujours répondre
de la même façon
au problème qui se répète puisqu'on y
répond toujours la même façon
et c'est celui qui fait que au-delà de
la formation parfois commune de ceux qui
produisent la norme de parcours même de
vie extrêmement commun le conformisme de
la norme vient à mon sens du fait que
ceux qui produisent la norme je pense
pas au législateur parce que vous tout à
l'heure vous êtes fait un exercice un
peu de taux flagellation je pense que
législateur très souvent il essaie de
d'adapter au contraire il y a des
contre-exemples mais enfin je pense pas
que ce soit les sénateurs ou les
parlementaires sous la sécurité qui soit
responsables de la loi climat résilience
voilà voilà il y a une CMP vous êtes
face à un devoir de responsabilité vous
devez conclure cette loi il y a eu une
CMP je crois la plus longue il y a une
des plus longues de l'histoire du
Parlement mais
juste pour conclure
il faut faire attention à ce que l'appel
à la simplification et au terrain de
cette traduisent pas par des règles qui
accentuent les problèmes et je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur le danger de
la différenciation alors je suis
peut-être audacieux en disant cela
je suis pour ma part un grand adepte de
la décentralisation mais pas de la
décentralisation asymétrique sauf
exception sur des ruptures territoriales
très fortes le caractère outremer
insulaire etc enfin dans certains cas de
figure et je crois que ce qu'il faut que
l'on arrive à faire c'est à ce que le
droit redevienne à ses fondamentaux
c'est-à-dire qu'il définit des principes
généraux des grands principes généraux
et que on recrée une société de la
confiance donc de la responsabilité et
qu'ensuite le pouvoir d'adaptation
réglementaire doit pas être un pouvoir
de différenciation de la loi parce que
moi je ne souhaite pas pouvoir déroger
je veux décider ce qui n'est pas la même
chose et être sanctionné sur ces
décisions positivement négativement et
donc que plutôt que de multiplier ce qui
entrave a priori dans des schémas
directeurs
on retrouve une puissance publique qui
intervient régalienne a posteriori pour
sanctionner et remettre sur le droit
chemin
c'est une révolution copernicienne qui
nous ramène à la base même de notre
organisation sociale et notre droit et
de ce qui a fait la grandeur
des démocraties libérales
la dérogation est un pouvoir arbitraire
c'est pour ça que les préfets
n'utilisent pas
parce que on leur demande de déroger à
la loi c'est-à-dire qu'on crée des lois
qui sont beaucoup trop monolithiques
dont on se rend compte qu'elles ne sont
pas applicables regardez et Serru vous
êtes résilience va nous
occuper pendant une vingtaine d'années
et donc on refait ensuite on recrée des
textes qui permettent de sortir de la
loi que l'on a créé je pense qu'il faut
sortir cette absurdité avoir le courage
d'accepter de distinguer ce qui relève
de l'ordre spontané d'escalade de
l'organisation pour citer un autre grand
libéral qui aiek
c'est absolument majeur et vous verrez
que c'est contre-intuitif en France
ça va à l'encontre de tout ce qu'on nous
a mis dans la tête donc bref il faut
redécouvrir la subsidiarité
et que
si l'État à travers toutes ces
émanations
dans le pouvoir normatif et législatives
s'il pouvait renoncer
à la prétention d'être seul
et bien bientôt il cesserait
pardon je vais je vais bien citer Guizot
parce que c'est du Guizot que l'État
renonce à la prétention d'être tout et
bientôt il cessera d'être seul
cette prétention d'être tout c'est celle
qui consiste à vouloir tout prévoir dans
des schémas directeur et des textes
laissons un pouvoir réglementaire aux
collectivités territoriales
respectueux de grandes dispositions
d'ordre public et de droit et vous
verrez qu'on aura beaucoup moins de
production normatives beaucoup plus
d'actions publiques et
une démocratie qui sera régénérée merci
de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci David Lisnard pour ce propos
introductif nous verrons tout à l'heure
si l'État le gouvernement à travers
Christophe Béchu prend les engagements
que vous souhaitez qu'ils prennent dans
l'immédiat nous passons au témoignages
des lulocko nous allons d'abord projeter
un petit film qui est un témoignage de
Thibault Philippe maire de
Illkirch-Graffenstaden c'est dans le
Bas-Rhin 26000 habitants il nous livre
son témoignage sur le poids et l'impact
des normes sur sa gestion locale si la
régie peut nous envoyer le petit film
ici les toute cette parcelle là est
vraiment
dévolu à accueillir le maraîchage et on
souhaite construire un bâtiment type
ferme et on fait un projet qui permet
d'alimenter à la fois les cantines de la
ville mais aussi peut-être de faire de
la vente en direct aux habitants mais
pour garder ses champs à l'état agricole
le maire fait face à un casse-tête
administratif le sort de cette terre est
scellé dans un PLU un Plan Local
d'Urbanisme
la précédente équipe municipale voulait
transformer ses espaces en logement mais
le nouveau maire décide de les maintenir
à l'état agricole il doit donc
transformer une ZAC une zone
d'aménagement concerté en Zap zone
d'agriculture de proximité et donc on
est parti pour 2 ans de procédure
d'enquête publique enfin voilà c'est pas
aujourd'hui un problème de financement
ou de candidats c'est un problème
aujourd'hui de normes des règles qui se
sont multipliées ces dernières années de
nombreux mères dénoncent des procédures
à rallonge pour eux des freins l'action
elles sont aussi un motif
d'incompréhension souvent évoquées par
les administrés on passe aussi même
vis-à-vis du citoyen pour pour des gens
pas toujours sérieux qui suivent pas les
dossiers et l'usager se dit mais enfin
pour c'est très compliqué pour pour pas
grand chose parce que le résultat à la
fin quand vous le voyez vous vous dites
pas qu'on a réalisé un viaduc ou qu'on a
créé une nouvelle ligne de chemin de fer
enfin voilà il y a rien d'exceptionnel
ça ça rend les choses plus complexes
j'ai le sentiment quand même qu'il y a
une perte financière parce que la durée
vous la payez de toute façon et plus ça
dure longtemps plus vous payez il
demande donc une simplification des
procédures pour cet élu une nécessité
d'intérêt général c'est ça on fait pas
forcément confiance au bon sens et on a
l'impression qu'en fait à chaque fois on
nous rajoute on aura rajoute des règles
qui se sur rajoutent déjà
à la rivière des règles face à laquelle
à chaque fois on se heurte l'abondance
et la complexité des normes ont un coût
pour la commune Illkirch doit employer
des juristes pour guider l'action de
l'administration
voilà pour ce petit film ce petit
témoignage
nous allons maintenant passer au
témoignage des lieux locaux d'autres
élus locaux ce témoignage nous a montré
que l'urbanisme est un des principaux
domaines où le poids des normes est
déplorés par les élus locaux nous allons
voir un autre domaine dans lequel il
peut être débloré avec Yvan lubranevski
vous êtes maire des Molière 1900
habitants dans l'Essonne et vous vouliez
porter votre témoignage ou apporter
votre témoignage sur le poids des normes
dans le domaine de la gestion des
ressources humaines de la fonction
publique territoriale qui n'est pas
spontanément d'ailleurs le domaine
auquel on pense mais qui est un vrai
sujet de complexité pour vous en tant
qu'employeur public nous vous écoutons
il y a merci merci encore de cette
initiative de la part de la délégation
du Sénat aux collectivités
et
souhaitons que que cela débouche
somme tous ici comme le disait notre
président des maires de France
nous avons envie que que cela que cela
aboutisse mais ça fait un peu longtemps
que nous le souhaitons
je reprends quelques principes généraux
également
peut-être
parce qu'il est bon d'insister dessus ça
faisait partie justement des des
conclusions dont
David Isnard parlé c'est c'est un vrai
sujet de cohésion nationale cette
affaire de loi
plus on en met dans la loi finalement
moins elle est respectée parce que si on
peut beaucoup déroger et moi et plus on
s'écarte finalement du principe général
de la loi qui
qui doit être reconnu au sein de la
société et puis reconnu donc par les
élus locaux les élus locaux ce sont des
élus qui
porte bien le nom ils sont élus et ils
sont et ils sont prêts à être contrôlés
en tant que tel mais ils ont
ils ont dans leur main un mandat
et ça finalement un moment donné on
s'écarte un peu aussi de cet esprit là
de l'esprit de la liberté municipale
lorsque finalement quand vous allez
voulez aller au bout de votre projet
finalement vous rencontrez un tas de
personnes qui vont intervenir sur
le processus
qui finalement semble avoir beaucoup
plus de droits sur le projet que
vous-même en tant que représentante de
de l'intérêt de l'intérêt général et
donc voilà il y a un problème quand même
structurel évidemment qui peut déborder
sur le sentiment que les citoyens ont
sur des choses qui sont quelquefois
relativement simple
David star disait tout à l'heure sur
l'assainissement je vois la question
aussi moi y compris sur ma commune sur
le le ruissellement
le risque d'aller beaucoup plus vite que
notre capacité quelquefois à l'arrêter
lorsqu'elle lorsqu'elle ruisselle et
évidemment l'habitant qui la reçoit dans
son sous-sol ne comprend pas pourquoi
nous procrastinons c'est aussi
c'est aussi un exemple donc je pense
qu'il faut saluer cette cette
démarche qui consisterait à réinterroger
la nécessité de la loi c'est ce que vous
voulez inscrire également dans
l'engagement et vous voulez faire signer
aussi le gouvernement une bonne idée
effectivement bon tout le monde a sa
part dans dans l'inflation normative
mais
il va falloir quand même
arriver et aboutir à quelque chose et
quelquefois simplification
ça finit en complexité on le voit
sur le terrain et
il y a un mot qu'on utilise peu c'est
abrogation il y a peut-être des choses
qui pourraient disparaître et j'en viens
effectivement à cet exemple sur les
ressources humaines les ressources
humaines le fait que les agents de la
des collectivités et des carrières et
que celle-ci puisse être
accompagnée
c'est indéniable le fait que une
collectivité est besoin d'agent
pour le projet du territoire pour mettre
pour faire mettre en place les services
municipaux c'est une réalité aussi mais
effectivement lorsque on voyait la
différence entre les codes tout à
l'heure au niveau de leur taille la
façon dont ils ont enflé ça a été
rappelé
mais il y a le droit du travail
il y a le code général des collectivités
territoriales il y a la fonction
publique territoriale et cette
empilement un moment donné quelquefois
contradictoires quelquefois évidemment à
l'échelle d'une commune rurale encore
plus
encore plus délicat
à appliquer parce que il faut passer par
le médecin du travail parce que il faut
la vie du comité technique paritaire
voilà alors moi je prononcerai
volontiers là on n'est pas là pour faire
la loi mais je sais pas si je le faisais
voté est-ce qu'on pourrait pas arrêter
avec le tableau des emplois voilà le
tableau des emplois tout le monde
connaît ici je pense mais
quand vous en êtes réduit dans un
conseil municipal ou finalement
vous avez 80 % des délibérations de la
soirée qui ne sont là que pour
satisfaire la norme
décider de la création de trois postes à
3 grades différents pour le même besoin
de la collectivité pour être sûr qu'on
puisse dans les temps
satisfaire ce besoin c'est de bien
complètement incroyable évidemment il
faudra donc en défaire deux une fois
qu'on aura recruté la personne
correspondant au grade de l'une des
trois
délibération
sans rappeler que cette délibération
donc elle va être
elle va être photocopiée autant de la
dématérialisation quand même le maire le
sait puisque ça se retrouve dans son
parapheur et que c'est le genre de
choses qui va signer plusieurs fois sans
compter évidemment tous les arrêtés qui
vont suivre
il y a un moment donné où sans
forcer la comparaison d'une collectivité
locale avec une entreprise
nous ne sommes ni plus ni moins des
employeurs au regard du droit du travail
essentiellement il faudrait revenir
à cet aspect
logiciel en quoi ça nous coûte ça a été
rappelé par notre collègue au milieu de
son chant c'est quoi c'est que
on passe plus de temps à répondre à
toutes ces questions de normes et on
passe moins de temps sur nos projets et
c'est nos projets qui construisent
l'avenir c'est nos projets qui font de
la commande publique pour faire
fonctionner aussi les entreprises et
avant qu'effectivement sur ce chant il y
ait une carotte qui finissent dans
l'assiette des enfants à la cantine
voyez bien que
sans compter évidemment que ça sort pas
comme ça d'un champ une carotte il
faudra aussi un travail préalable mais
finalement on va passer beaucoup plus de
temps à tergiverser une fois de plus
pour un élu de la République qui est élu
sur un projet qui manifestement ensuite
peut aussi avoir des projets en cours de
mandat et des partager avec les
habitants avec le conseil municipal qui
va valider quand même un certain nombre
d'étapes et bien il va y avoir toute une
série de de
d'instance ou d'associations
au projet qui vont à un moment donné
démunir ou freiner freiner véritablement
le projet
urbanisme c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un autre exemple que je voulais
donner je veux pas deuxième langue parce
qu'on a un timing très très serré sur
l'urbanisme
c'est plutôt peut-être du point de vue
du demandeur on est
on est sur un dossier pour une
déclaration préalable de travaux qui est
passé de une à huit pages voilà en
quelques en quelques années c'est vrai
qu'il y a des pages où il y a presque
rien dessus mais voilà les gens sont
toujours étonnés quand ils arrivent
comme ça et puis que on leur présente le
dossier pour une clôture pour voilà
aujourd'hui on est dans le fond vert
peut-être que notre ministre en parlera
tout à l'heure sujet qui défend
évidemment ce sont des des
des apports en termes de subventions
pour les communes et au passage rappelé
qu'il existait une dotation de
subventions générale et qu'elle a été
morcelée en différentes choses qui sont
voilà on aligne les équations alors que
là pour l'occasion également sur les
dotations de l'État on pourra avoir une
seule dotation et puis en fonction du
projet va rentrer dans cette
différenciation au bon sens du terme
c'est pas c'est pas toujours le cas sur
le sur le fond vert
on a un exemple s'il vous plaît mon
collègue Bertrange corne publié l'autre
jour sur son sur son fil Facebook
on demande un moment donné sur
sur les économies d'énergie qui peuvent
être réalisés
à l'occasion d'un changement
de l'éclairage public on demande
précisément
la le rapport en termes de lumens et
apparemment y compris même les
opérateurs qui étaient autour de lui et
qui avait pu faire des estimatifs au
début il était incapable de répondre à
la question donc là encore les Luc local
il faut qu'il puisse s'inscrire dans le
projet et quand on va passer à aux
questions techniques c'est une autre
affaire mais être bloqué au moment
évidemment où est-ce qu'on nous le
demande sur le site que vous connaissez
pour certains qui s'appelle démarche
simplifier merci beaucoup
je conclue juste avec peut-être juste un
élément
donnez-nous confiance je pense que ça a
été rappelé par notre collègue et
président David Isnard donnez-nous
confiance et effectivement
faites au-delà du CNN qui est une agence
que je connais bien puisque
j'y siège aussi au-delà du cneen Créon
la proposition dont a parlé le sénateur
Cointreau tout à l'heure sur un comité
local avec le préfet créons des lieux
d'échanges de façon à ce que l'univers
de la réalité et le process législatif
se rend compte beaucoup plus pour que
nous soyons plus efficaces merci merci
c'est une effectivement des propositions
du Sénat nous y reviendrons une instance
de concertation préfet élu Christophe
bouillon
bonjour vous êtes maire de Barentin vous
présiez l'association des petites villes
de France vous allez nous expliquer un
peu les résultats d'une consultation que
vous aviez vous-même mené auprès de vos
adhérents maire de petites villes et
donner quelques exemples concrets
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu'il faut respecter un timing très très
court trois quatre minutes je serai pas
des obligeant mais je suis obligé si
tout le monde parle trop nous n'aurons
pas le temps d'entendre tout le monde je
me tais à mon tour à vous merci d'abord
merci à Françoise Gatel et puis à Rémy
pointeau de nous permettre finalement de
porter tes témoignages dans le cadre de
ces états généraux de la simplification
donc il faut souhaiter qu'elle
neboutissent pas en fin de parcours à
une création de normes mais plutôt de
mode d'emploi c'est ça dont nous avons
je crois besoin l'association des
petites villes de France fédère des
territoires entre 2500 et 25000
habitants c'est dire que lorsque nous
réalisons une enquête flash pour
solliciter la vie de nos élus finalement
on fait parler l'ensemble des
départements des territoires ruraux ou
urbains et ça m'étonner personne ce que
nous disent nous élus à travers cette
enquête flash de rejoindre parfaitement
les constats que vous avez établi et qui
ont été rappelés tout à l'heure par Rémi
quattro auquel on pourrait aussi
associer le récent rapport du Conseil
national des variations des normes qui
convergent et tant mieux dans les
constats qui dit en effet que
concrètement pour l'ensemble des élus
cette boulimie des normes c'est à la
fois lourd cher long et parfois
décourageant j'insiste sur ce point
parce qu'on voit aussi beaucoup de
collectivités qui finissent par
abandonner
la portée de projet et je crois que ça
c'est plutôt ça doit nous inquiéter on
pourrait se dire ne pas aller jusqu'au
bout des projets pourquoi pas mais en
même temps concrètement ça a des effets
à la fois en termes d'attractivité en
termes de dynamique économique à
l'échelle des territoires alors pour
tenir les engagements de temps je
voudrais citer trois exemples de prix
sur ma commune et une prix pour faire
plaisir à notre président du Sénat dans
les dans les Yvelines
deux exemples sur ma commune le premier
c'est pour souligner ce qui était dit
tout à l'heure par EMI Cointreau en ce
qui concerne parfois les injonctions
contradictoires
on nous demande par exemple à travers le
décret tertiaire de veiller à une
meilleure isolation le bâtiments à
respecter en écart en tout cas des
consommations moindres énergétiques et
en même temps il y a aussi la question
importante qui est celle de
l'accessibilité concrètement quand vous
avez par exemple à procéder à une
isolation thermique d'un bâtiment par
l'extérieur quand les bâtiments sont
assez anciens et bien vous êtes
confrontés à cet enjeu qui est celui de
l'accessibilité pour respecter un
certain nombre de largeurs deuxième
exemple
assez simple
on a aujourd'hui c'est injonction en
termes d'économie par rapport à aux
ressources on parle beaucoup d'énergie
mais il faut parler aussi de l'eau quand
des collectivités aujourd'hui veulent
par exemple réduire les consommations
d'eau générée dans les écoles ou dans
d'autres bâtiments notamment des
bâtiments sportifs par exemple en
voulant utiliser les eaux de pluie ou
les eaux usées des du lave-main par
exemple après traitement elles ont soit
empêché par les normes c'est à dire
qu'on leur demande aux collectivités de
faire un effort important en termes
d'économie d'eau mais aujourd'hui c'est
une arme qui empêche d'aller plus loin
en la matière alors qu'on parle de ce
variété troisième et dernier exemple
prix dans les Yvelines dans la commune
de Villepreux c'est
administré par mon collègue
Jean-Baptiste
c'est l'histoire du poulailler mobile on
a aussi cette inflexion assez forte
aujourd'hui de favoriser les filières
courts de respecter les paps des
programmes alimentaires territoriaux
c'est ce qu'il souhaite faire simplement
il est confronté à un exercice qui a été
tout à l'heure dans le petit reportage
rappelé parfois on a le PLU qui percute
le PRI le PPRI sur des risques
inondations quand vous avez cela de sur
votre territoire je rappelle qu'il y a
quand même plus de 400 000 cours d'eau
en France c'est-à-dire que beaucoup de
territoires sont concernés par cette
exigence et ce risque il se dit dans ce
document qu'on peut permettre de
construire des équipements en dur mais
pas un poulailler qui est un équipement
peu considéré comme étant éphémère il
finit par trouver une solution
dans la cuvette quelque part sauf qu'on
lui dit bien évidemment étant dans la
plaine de Versailles qu'il faut pas que
depuis Versailles on puisse voir le
poulailler
[Musique]
le point de vue des collectivités doit
être celui qui doit donner une
définition de différenciation qui
empêche bien sûr la dérive qu'il
pointait par ailleurs qui est celle de
d'oublier aussi le rôle de l'État et
l'égalité aussi que l'on doit aux
collectivités dans ce domaine voilà je
serai pas plus long merci beaucoup
Christophe bouillon pour votre concision
aussi les exemples très concrets que
vous avez donné Marie-Claude Jarreau à
vos côtés maire de Montceau-les-Mines en
Saône-et-Loire quand on préparait votre
intervention vous me disiez il faut
trouver un juste milieu entre la jungle
des pourvu de toute règle de toute norme
et un jardin à la française qui
empêcherait toute action locale des élus
locaux nous vous écoutons témoignage et
point de vue
bonjour à vous toutes et à vous toutes
en vous grade ses qualités merci pour
cette belle initiative madame la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale je suis très honorée de
pouvoir témoigner devant vous alors je
vais aller vite
vous m'avez donné des consignes je vais
essayer de les respecter
déjà
quatre phrases concernant cette le sujet
qui nous
occupe c'est sûr les normes nuisent à
l'attractivité de nos territoires
empêche que nous puissions travailler
sérieusement à l'attractivité de notre
étoile
parfois les normes nous démoralisent
nous désespèrent comme mes collègues
l'ont dit et empêche les élus locaux de
d'être optimiste et le président tout à
l'heure a parlé de des élus qui qui
perdent un peu espoir c'est une réalité
de territoire vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Pointreau c'est une réalité de
territoire que je constate en tant que
présidente des maires de Saône-et-Loire
la superposition des normes elle crée
des tunnels des complexités
incompréhensibles et puis je terminerai
ce propos liminaire en disant que les
normes créent des interactions avec les
autorités des concentrées qui sont des
interactions perdants perdants
crispation est de mauvaises interactions
je reparlerai des interactions tout à
l'heure alors
j'avais droit à cinq exemples je vais
aller vite 5 exemples premier exemple
rénover un complexe sportif c'est à dire
appliquer des normes dans le domaine
électrique dans le domaine sanitaire
dans le domaine de la transition
écologique et dans le domaine de l'accès
d'accession handicapée
on nous demande pour l'accession
handicapée évidemment c'est normal qu'on
nous demande ça on nous demande que
cette accession que le bâtiment soit
accessible partout le grand complexe
soit accessible partout alors qu'avant
il n'était accessible
nulle part il nous a fallu
casser les tribunes
toutes les tribus parce que accessibles
partout mettre deux ascenseurs alors que
nous avons dit que un seul ascenseur
suffisait on nous a obligé on nous a
obligé ce qui a créé un surcoût
financier très important nous n'avons
pas pour autant renoncé mais on peut
admettre que certains collègues auraient
certainement renoncé de guerlas
l'électricité les normes changent
pratiquement tous les trois ans et on
met plus de trois ans pour pour rénover
un grand complexe sportif le confort
thermique
décrétaire 40% d'économie 2030 2045 ans
2050 60
tout ça ça crée un effet multiplicateur
et ça et ça ça nuit à la qualité du
projet et ça peut faire renoncer au
projet de plus l'État la Région le
Département additionne des critères pour
être éligibles à la subvention et nous
ne remplissons pas toujours
tous les critères et philologie pour les
régions enfin je vous passe les termes
quelquefois incompréhensibles aussi donc
c'est un exemple de superposition des
normes on ne rentre presque jamais
jamais dans les dans on ne cause jamais
toutes les cases et là vous m'aviez
évoqué monsieur brivel la possibilité de
faire de parler de notre relation avec
l'État et là il faut une bonne relation
avec le sous-préfet ou avec le préfet et
ou avec le préfet pour que l'on puisse
cocher toutes les cases sinon on n'y
arrive pas on a cette superposition des
critères normatifs qui nous conduit à
quelquefois à un moment donné deuxième
exemple et nous en resterons un deuxième
exemple si vous voulez bien car je vous
repasserai la parole après je vous
promets mais si on veut un temps de
débattre
j'espère pouvoir installer faire vos
photosvoltaïques sur un terrain et sur
enfin sur une friche et sur un lac
un lac minier la pas de problème de Zana
mais le fond friche n'est pas ouvert
à cela parce que c'est pas une friche où
l'on va reconstruire une usine ou des
logements c'est simplement pour
conserver un patrimoine on restaure on
met en valeur un patrimoine industriel
aucun levier pour assurer la transition
de cette friche la norme pour le coup la
norme a oublié ce cas qui n'est pas
InCar rare sur les territoires
industriels ou sur les territoires
historiques
donc la norme a oublié la préservation
du patrimoine par contre et c'est là
toute l'absurdité si nous avions détruit
ce patrimoine on rentrerait dans le fond
friche
parce qu'on poursuivrait des objectifs
transition aménagement du territoire
alors que en préservant un patrimoine
ont poursuit aussi ces mêmes objectifs
sur cette friche sur cette même friche
pour financer sa conservation je termine
je me dépêche
nous allons produire de l'électricité le
jour mais aujourd'hui à ce moment où je
vous parle la loi favorise un peu la
position prépondérante des déesses et
son lobbying et
ralentit l'évolution des textes qui doit
permettre aux collectivités de revendre
de l'électricité pour financer les
investissements
mais la matinée est très chargée claire
de main que votre voisine juriste
avocate et rédactrice en chef de
l'agctualité juridique des collectivités
territoriales avec vous c'est l'oeil
d'une praticienne du droit votre rôle
c'est justement d'expliquer de décrypter
la réglementation notamment aux élus
locaux quel œil vous portez sur ce
maquis normatif 4 5 minutes pas plus
s'il vous plaît j'étais en train de tout
couper alors merci Monsieur merci madame
la Présidente pour votre invitation j'ai
je coupe je coupe je coupe parce que il
y a déjà énormément de choses qui ont
été dites moi j'interviens ici à côté
des élus pour témoigner donc à mon tour
de l'inflation normative mais ma
pratique elle diffère quelques peu de
mes voisins moi j'ai pas les mains dans
le cambouis ou dans le poulailler mobile
je savais même pas que ça existait voilà
j'ai les mains dans le JO donc mon
travail consiste avec un certain nombre
de collègues des éditions Lefebvre
daloza a dépouillé le Journal officiel
du matin et oui j'ai mon stock de
doliprane chaque matin et j'essaye de
suivre le rythme des textes publiés je
vous invite à lire le journal officiel
en fin d'année autour du 31 décembre
c'est la fête voilà le Faivre d'Allos
donc Edith a un mensuel à destination
des jeunesse de collectivités
l'actualité juridique des collectivités
territoriales et de nombreux codes que
vous connaissez on en a parlé de
certains le CGCT le code général des
collectivités territoriales le code de
l'urbanisme qui fait mal le code général
de la Fonction publique et comme il y a
rien de tel que l'image
dans le métro j'ai pas pu tout se les
rapporter voilà ça c'est le poids des
normes expliquez-nous alors le premier
et le second
de 82
il date de 82 le code de l'urbanisme il
comptait 600 pages magnifique un beau
papier
celui de 2022
toujours en papier mais en papier bible
cette fois-ci il en compte 3600
le code général des collectivités
territoriales de 1996 un peu plus gros
déjà puisqu'on avait compris que c'était
difficile de tout faire rentrer dans le
petit format et celui de 2023 voilà donc
ça c'est parlant je peux me cacher
derrière comme vous pouvez le voir
et donc pour filer la métaphore de la
maladie qui vous est cher
oui
ils sont plus grands et le papier le
papier est différent
et les caractères sont plus petits il y
a plus de marge et il tenait dans la
poche le but à l'époque c'était le livre
de poche c'est loin d'être le livre de
poche et elle est le prix non plus le
prix d'un livre de pas cher alors claire
de main les raisons de cette inflation
normative
de la maladie donc les codes sont
aujourd'hui obèses voilà vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous avez utilisé ce terme
alors bien sûr c'est un peu facile aussi
c'est l'image il y a d'autres choses le
sujet il est plus subtil il n'empêche je
reviens toujours à Victor Hugo parce
qu'on a beaucoup cité mais moi j'aime
beaucoup Victor Hugo la forme c'est le
fond qui remonte à la surface et donc il
faut toujours quand même s'arrêter à ces
images là je vais faire hyper court
puisque les sujets ont été abordés de
façon très intelligente jusqu'à
maintenant et je renvoie aux coloc qui a
eu lieu le 14 octobre dernier sur la
simplification normative qui a été
organisée par le Conseil d'État et le
cnen et qui est librement accessible sur
le site du Conseil d'État sous la forme
de podcast aussi si vous voulez en
ressortir plus intelligent sur ce sujet
mais je vous invite à y aller
donc trop de normes et elles sont
complexes je vais aller hyper vite j'ai
tout coupé tout d'abord on en a parlé
les normes répondent à des besoins
légitimes à une société qui se
complexifie je prendrais juste l'exemple
de l'intelligence artificielle on a
parlé de l'environnement effectivement
des injonctions contradictoires mais on
a aussi une aujourd'hui une société qui
s'interne nationalise et qui tout
simplement techniquement de plus en plus
compliqué il est énorme ne sont que le
reflet de la société et je dirais c'est
plutôt bien d'ailleurs on en a parlé la
complexité c'est pas forcément un mal
c'est effectivement sans doute la
complication qu'on est vous avez parlé
de l'urgence
la loi magique qui répond à une émotion
on en parle souvent en droit pénal
c'est souvent dans ce cas là mais ça
peut être le cas dans d'autres
situations La Faute-sur-Mer on peut
parler de d'autres situations et la
question on agit dans l'urgence on prend
un test on vote une loi en réponse en
fait à une émotion à une émotion
générale et on se pose pas la question
de l'Arsenal législative pré-existant et
ça c'est un vrai problème puisqu'on
empile au lieu de se poser de réfléchir
et quand on rédige dans l'urgence on
rédige mal quand on fait vite les choses
on fait mal globalement
nous on le voit puisque nous on
consolide nos codes donc on voit quand
c'est plutôt bien fait ou quand c'est
plutôt mal fait
de même quand on simplifie on
complexifie c'est un peu les Shadoks
pourquoi faire simple quand on peut
faire compliqué le Conseil d'État
relevait dans son étude annuel en 2016
qui avait 130 textes de simplification
qui avait été adopté en dix ans si ça
avait été totalement efficace on serait
pas réuni aujourd'hui donc je vous
donnerai juste un exemple de
simplification contre-productif de ces
dernières années qui est le silence veut
acceptation personne n'en a parlé si moi
ça m'avait frappé le silence va
acceptation ou plutôt le silence vos
refus voilà pour moi c'est vraiment ce
sont les Shadoks là c'est vraiment
kafkaïen de par la liste d'exclusion
c'est ça qui avait été une exception
puis même la mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui
est-ce que quelqu'un est capable de
parler du silence va acceptation de
façon concrète
juste c'est très intéressant moi je suis
souscrit
quand il y a eu le parce que c'était
parti d'un vrai très beau travail de
Thierry Bandon etc demandée par François
Hollande et à la fin moi je l'ai vécu
dans ma commune il y a eu ensuite la
machine Matrix qui arrive là ça broie le
Léviathan le nombre de dérogations et de
ce qui signifie que pour savoir si vous
devez répondre ou pas il fallait moi
recruter quelqu'un dans ma commune
donc on a décidé de répondre à tout le
monde ce qu'on faisait déjà avant voilà
donc c'est typiquement c'est un
excellent exemple de l'absurdité
ubuesque de tout cela le gouvernement
avait envisagé à l'époque de créer une
un logiciel une petite une application
sur laquelle en fait les citoyens
pouvaient répondre vous pouvez poser la
question est-ce que ça c'est un silence
c'est un quatre silence vocation ils ont
dû abandonner au bout de 6 mois ce qui
était impossible de dresser la liste
voilà on y arrive pas
j'ai évacurai le droit européen mais ça
ça mérite qu'on s'y attarde oui car on
se contente pas de transcrire vous
disiez madame
en soit c'est pas forcément un mal on
adapte la norme à des exigences à des
nécessités nationales mais ça participe
à la réglementation le comble étant
quand on adopte des lois pour lutter
contre la surtransposition donc là c'est
ça donne le vertige je donnerai un autre
exemple le code général de la Fonction
publique le travail la codification a
été menée de façon excellente l'objectif
poursuivi il était très
il était très honorable il se trouve que
au fur et à mesure du moment de de
l'utilisation qu'il y a entre un an on
se rend compte qu'il y a des petites
subtilités d'un point de vue pratique
notamment par exemple la journée du
premier mai je sais que beaucoup en ont
parlé puisque le CGFP renvoie au code du
travail dorénavant pour rémuner les
rémunérer les agents publics qui
travaillent le 1er mai ce qui était pas
le cas auparavant donc un petit
complexité voilà petite chose frappe
petite surprise en fait
donc je dirais trop de normes des normes
complexes je citerai des exemples de
gros gros gros textes 177 articles pour
la loi alur 234 pour la loi Elan et 271
articles pour la loi 3DS et beaucoup de
décrets
et pas forcément pris dans les délais
d'ailleurs mais pour ça
mais on en a pas parlé il faut qu'on
parle aussi de l'instabilité de la norme
il me semble que quand le code de la
commande publique a été a été est entré
en vigueur avant même d'ailleurs qu'il
entre en vigueur il y avait déjà des
textes qui étaient pris pour modifier le
futur code de la commande publique en
fait on passe notre temps à courir après
après une norme qui soit relativement
stable ça peut décourager donc
aujourd'hui le risque c'est celui d'une
norme qui est peu intelligible on a
parlé mais qui est difficilement
accessible des textes qui procèdent par
envoi j'en ai parlé avec le CGFP le CGCT
une mise en oeuvre différée
et c'est très compliqué on peut
l'entendre pour ceux qui ne sont pas
experts moi j'interviens comme juriste
aussi puisque nos codiste nous sommes
juristes
moi sincèrement je frémis des froid
quand je dois ouvrir le code général des
impôts donc même pour des gens qui
peuvent se déclarer experts aujourd'hui
le droit est très complexe donc
très bien je conclus un petit Bose
conclusion je conclus sur un exemple qui
peut paraître caricatural mais je trouve
qu'il est très parlant c'est un arrêt
rendu par la Cour administratif d'appel
de Douai en janvier ou une secrétaire de
mairie avait falsifié la signature du
maire sur des documents afin d'obtenir
le versement d'heure supplémentaires
qu'elle n'avait pas à réaliser
et pour constester la sanction qui lui
était infligée elle arguait de son
faible niveau de qualification alors
bien sûr
on était en face de la mauvaise foi la
plus pure puisque si elle avait usurpé
la signature de son mère qu'elle l'avait
pas réalisé ses heures supplémentaires
on était en face d'une fraude mais je
trouve que c'est quand même assez
parlant puisqu'elle a quand même estimé
que elle n'était pas assez formée
qu'elle ne connaissait pas la loi et ça
il faut l'entendre je pense dans la
pratique quotidienne
d'ailleurs je ne s'en avais parlé
monsieur Lisnard nul n'est censé ignorer
la loi mais elle est parfois très
difficile à connaître quant à la
maîtriser je vous laisse je vous laisse
juge merci beaucoup pour votre
intervention
nous avons
cinq à dix minutes maximum de débat avec
vous si des personnes dans la salle ont
envie de témoigner de commenter de
réagir vous prenez la parole vous me
faites signe vous levez la main vous
vous présentez s'il vous plaît nom
prénom fonction et vous posez vous
faites une intervention s'il vous plaît
très courte monsieur
oui vous appuyez normalement sur un
bouton rouge voilà oui moi je suis maire
de Fontenay-aux-Roses dans le 92 on a
beaucoup parlé de l'impact financier
finalement mais il y a une vraie
question qui est l'impact sur la
temporalité des projets en fait c'est à
dire qu'en fait aujourd'hui entre la
décision politique et le début de la
réalisation c'est le début des travaux
il y a un temps qui devient de tellement
important que d'abord il y a un
phénomène d'oubli puis il y a un fait
d'exploitation parfois par des gens qui
peuvent ne pas être favorables au projet
on voit se multiplier éventuellement des
recours comment plus le droit de
l'individu aujourd'hui et parfois plus
important que le droit collectif on
rallonge encore le projet et on va
arriver on arrive pour certains projets
comme ça a été dit d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure par Lazzaro la révélation d'un
gros gymnase on est à la limite de
pouvoir faire ça dans un mandat quoi et
donc en fait on voit bien que dans un
certain nombre de cas on déborde
finalement sur la durée du mandat
municipal et c'est vrai que ça devient
quand même une vraie problématique
c'est-à-dire que faut se dépêcher et on
voit que tous les marchés publics les
entreprises même sont sollicités au même
moment dans les mandats parce que il
faut se dépêcher parce que sinon on
n'aura pas le temps en fait de de livrer
le projet avant la fin du mandat et donc
on c'est une forme de stérilisation
aussi d'un certain nombre de projets
qu'on sait très bien ne pas pouvoir
réaliser dans les délais impartis et je
pense c'est un vrai handicap pour les
communes merci pour ce témoignage une
des façons peut-être de d'accélérer de
concilier ce temps législatif
réglementaire et ce temps politique
c'est peut-être aussi
la capacité à adapter l'application de
la norme dans les témoignages que qu'on
a entendu ce matin ça n'a pas été
vraiment évoqué ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est si les uns les autres vous
êtes parvenu avec le préfet l'architecte
des bâtiments de France la DREAL a
adapté
la norme la règle aux spécificités de
votre territoire madame Jarreau est-ce
que par exemple vous avez réussi à
trouver un modus opérandi
excusez-moi je crois que je l'avais mis
tout dépend de la personnalité du préfet
avec lequel on travaille et de et de sa
volonté de nous accompagner bon moi j'ai
eu la chance depuis que je suis maire
d'avoir des préfets qui nous ont qui
m'ont toujours accompagné néanmoins
néanmoins malgré cela quelquefois nous
n'arrivons pas à démarrer les projets ou
à faire en sorte que les projets soient
suivis je donnais un exemple une chose
que je n'ai jamais réussi à faire à ce
jour ça fait 8 ans 8 ans que je suis
mère l'entretien des paires
c'est impossible impossible de d'avoir
un entretien régulier des paires tout
simplement parce qu'il y a des
conventions de superposition VNF
état enfin VNFC l'État et puis et puis
et puis
des personnes le PCI on se rejette la
responsabilité des choses qu'on ne peut
pas faire même en interpellant même en
interpellant le préfet le préfet il a
intervient pour nous donner pour dire
alors bon je ne dirai rien sur ce sujet
on va faire comme ça on va donner
l'autorisation malgré le fait que vous
n'ayez pas vous n'ayez pas respecté
toutes les procédures mais il faut avoir
un préfet considère c'est toujours dans
le cas d'une relation
qu'il ne soit pas frileux sur le risque
de contentieux si elle vous aide à
adapter le règlement je me permets juste
de dire là-dessus parce que c'est
essentiel ce qui manque c'est notre
affection doit aussi concerner la
décentration des services de l'État et
c'est fondamental parce que
aujourd'hui le préfet ne peut pas être
le juge de paix qu'il devrait être
et même la notion de dire est-ce qu'on
peut adapter la norme au terrain moi
j'aurais fait ça une énorme si elle doit
être modifiée par rapport à un projet
c'est qu'il y a un problème une norme
par définition facile à base du droit
quoi c'est à dire cette norme en fait
cette modalité devenue une finalité
c'est-à-dire que la norme est devenue
une finalité et donc c'est que ça ne
fonctionne pas et alors si pour aller
vite on pourrait dire il peut y avoir
une instance de d'arbitrage bon au sens
premier du terme et que ce serait le
préfet sauf qu'aujourd'hui dans la
réalité c'est pas adapté la norme c'est
que les normes se contredit le préfet
n'a pas d'autorité sur un DDTM sauf
exception et encore moins surréal et on
le voit très bien sur ce qui était
évoqué tout à l'heure sur les eaux les
gémapis ce que vous évoquez c'est à dire
que moi je l'ai vécu des bassins des
ouvrages de protection des populations
qui sont soutenus par les préfets les
sous préfets les délétés ou des DTM
selon le coin et qui sont plantés par la
DREAL
et chacun dans sa norme donc
on est au coeur du sujet alors c'est
peut-être pour ça monsieur Lisnard que
vous demandez au nom de la MF le
transfert d'un pouvoir réglementaire à
l'échelon local comment ça se passerait
ça c'est brièvement
c'est que en revienne à des grandes
dispositions de droit public et des
grandes lois qui fixent des objectifs
avec des évaluations des clauses de
rendez-vous etc et qu'ensuite et donc la
loi serait la même pour tout le monde
moi je suis attaché à cela mais
qu'ensuite la mise en oeuvre de la loi
dépend d'un pouvoir réglementaire qui
serait transféré aux collectivités selon
le type de loi d'objectif c'est un autre
débat ensuite au cas par cas et que le
temps ensuite contrôler vérifie et ça
changerait tout parce que dans le
conformisme que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est lorsque vous n'êtes pas
dans la dans le dans l'exigence du
praticien
vous vous
ne pouvez produire que que des textes
qui seront forcément déconnectés de la
réalité des objectifs c'est obligatoire
c'est comme un médecin qui voit jamais
un malade quoi c'est pas c'est pas
terrible effectivement madame Gatel et
ensuite je prends un témoignage dans la
salle
merci beaucoup pour cette intervention
qui montre vous l'avez dit la complexité
des choses et que je pense que si nous
identifions clairement les symptômes du
mal qui nous ronge et nous connaissons
un peu les remèdes ils sont multiples et
ce que nous proposons aujourd'hui doit
aller de père avec une évaluation
systémique de ce qu'il faut de ce qu'il
faut mettre en avant on a parlé un peu
de différenciation on a aussi beaucoup
dit et David Lisnard vient de leur dire
et beaucoup d'entre vous on doit
élaborer des lois qui permettent des
possibles c'est-à-dire des adaptations
dans l'unité de la République et non pas
des lois qui interdisent obligent et
enfin je regarde mes collègues
sénateurs et notamment Agnès canaillé
qui avait ericaouche au nom de la
négation collectivité on produit un
remarquable
un remarquable travail sur alors qui
s'appelle le Sénat est sérieux mais peut
être drôle
s'appelle mieux et donc ils ont appelé
le rapport à la recherche de l'État dans
les territoires effectivement nous avons
une vraie difficulté de déficit de
l'accompagnement de l'État pour aider
les collectivités à mettre en œuvre les
choses on peut parler d'usage
aujourd'hui il y a une circulaire du
préfet qui vous dit voilà alors le zan
c'est ça je parle pas des communes où la
secrétaire de mairie est là deux jours
et demi par semaine voilà et donc on met
une angoisse folle sur les une pression
folle sur les mains alors que je pense
que les préfets les devraient être
proactifs venir expliquer la loi aux
élus et accompagner les élus dans la
réalisation donc quand on parle d'un
changement de culture c'est ça mais il
faut vraiment qu'on muscle aussi les
services déconcentrés de l'État et
l'action pédagogique et l'action
pédagogique et qu'on est un préfet qui
est vraiment de l'autorité c'est-à-dire
quand vous êtes mains et vous racontez
vos histoires vous partez sur un
parcours du combat de temps qui fait que
vous allez voir ladreal ensuite vous
allez voir la BF ensuite vous allez voir
la DDTM donc les portes se ferment au
fur et à mesure derrière vous et parfois
vous avez un sous-préfet qui peut vous
dire j'aimerais beaucoup dire à l'adréal
ça suffit mais je ne peux pas parce que
je n'ai pas autorité sur lui ce qui veut
dire que le préfet doit incarner l'État
et permettre qu'on parle d'une seule
voilà simplification mais aussi là merci
deux petites interventions monsieur de
Madame dans le fond monsieur si vous
pouvez vous présenter Sacha Eva que mère
de Cézanne dans la Marne donc juste vous
souhaitiez deux petits exemples donc je
rejoins tout à fait les propos qui ont
été présentés jusqu'à présent et ce que
je regrette c'est un petit peu de
constater le manque de bon sens dans la
loi par deux exemples la mobilité
aujourd'hui sur mon territoire donc
centre bourg isolé j'ai souhaité mettre
une navette intra-muros en place déjà
pour le Claver les quartiers de mon
centre ville et une navette extra bureau
rose pour faire en sorte que les les
petits villages environnants puissent
revenir sur le centre bois donc la loi
de retrait nous a demandé de porter
compétences qui a été donné dans un
premier temps à la région la région nous
a dit est-ce que l'intercommunalité
souhaite récupérer cette compétence
l'intercommunalité à récupérer la
compétence mais ne souhaite pas financer
les projets des communes donc j'ai
sollicité effectivement
l'intercommunalité en disant de quelle
manière est-ce que la ville de Cézanne
peut financer intégralement son projet
sans demander un sous à
l'intercommunalité et là vite juridique
on m'explique ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas votre compétence vous ne
pouvez pas agir premier exemple deuxième
exemple donc nous sommes très attachés à
notre patrimoine dans notre commune
petite cité de caractères on a un
certain nombre de bâtiments qui sont en
péril et à ce titre donc moi j'ai des
propriétaires privés qui me disent
écoutez il y a pas de souci du bâtiment
on le connaît ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
en ruine si vous indiquez aux
propriétaires que effectivement il est
en péril je m'engage à le racheter à la
réhabilité c'est un contrat moral on
peut le signer etc j'ai interpellé à ce
sujet le ministère avec un courrier qui
avait été porté par le député Charles de
Courson pour savoir comment est-ce
qu'une commune pouvait récupérer
un immeuble en péril si il n'avait pas
de projet derrière et bien j'attends
encore la réponse puisqu'il y invite
juridique donc voilà simplement deux
exemples pour vous dire qu'on multiplie
la norme on multiplie les règles par
contre quand on a des cas concrets et
qu'on cherche des solutions on n'a pas
les réponses donc faudra peut-être
qu'effectivement se poser les bonnes
questions alors on verra si le Sénat
dans ses propositions permettra de
régler ce genre de choses on n'y arrive
presque une intervention dans le fond et
une très très courte devant vous je vais
faire court Anne-Laure Philippe et je
suis DGS d'une collectivité
périurbaine et néanmoins morale au sud
d'Ajaccio je représente aujourd'hui le
maire de Grosset auproux qui est
souffrante je vois dans la superposition
des normes une sorte de différentes
couches d'enrobées qu'on voit sur nos
voiries dans les collectivités on
superpose on superpose on enrobe on en
robe et un jour ça casse et actuellement
j'ai plein de bulles beaucoup de buses
en galva qui casse et il faut tout
refaire et ça coûte extrêmement cher
j'ai l'impression que notre Parlement il
est un petit peu dans cette situation là
j'ai lu tout le rapport ce matin dans
l'avion en arrivant à Paris et je
félicite toute cette délégation qui pour
un travail extraordinaire avec beaucoup
de avec beaucoup de choses innovantes je
regrette que cet instance de dialogue
qui avait été créé et accepté par le
Sénat a été ensuite et puis ensuite être
retour par l'Assemblée nationale c'est
dommage mais je vois dans ce rapport
beaucoup de choses sur la formation La
formation des hauts fonctionnaires que
je trouve très très bien cependant je
trouve qu'on s'éloigne et comme le
Parlement actuellement je trouve qu'on
s'éloigne des réalités de terrain je
rejoins je rejoins là beaucoup sur ce
point je pense que sur nos instances
notamment sur le CNN et sur ces
instances locales il faut intégrer les
élus locaux et il faut il faut intégrer
les fonctionnaires territoriaux je vois
pas beaucoup de DGS dans cette salle je
vois beaucoup sans doute d'étudiants ou
fonctionnaires ou de haut fonctionnaires
et des élus quelques élus peut-être
moins mais pas de fonctionnaires locaux
et je pense que des élus locaux et les
fonctionnaires locaux méritent d'être
aussi dans ces instances là merci je
pense que votre appel va être pris en
compte par le Sénat madame vous pouvez
appuyer sur le bouton rouge devant vous
et vous présenter s'il vous plaît merci
bonjour Esther Bayol je suis consultante
pour les collectivités et je voulais
simplement remonter un exemple qui va
dans le sens de ce que vous lisiez
madame Gatel sur l'importance des
services des concentrés la préfecture
enfin la DDTM des lentes par exemple
c'est doté de deux juristes qui sont
chargés d'accompagner les communes et
les collectivités sur le développement
de projets photovoltaïques parce que il
y a un vrai volontarisme et donc en
amont de la loi d'AC des renouvelables
qui prévoit des dérogations pour la loi
littorale la il y a eu plusieurs projets
qui ont été soumis à ce guichet unique
et qui ont permis d'obtenir des
dérogations à la continuation de
l'urbanisme qui est prévue dans la loi
littorale et qui a permis le
développement de projet par exemple sur
des sites dégradés et on voit que les
arguments et la le guichet unique a
permis aussi de d'améliorer les projets
en faisant en sorte qu'ils soient
réversibles par exemple et c'est un
voilà c'est un exemple de d'une de
service déconcentrés qui ont eu une
démarche volontariste et qui a mené avec
succès à de nouveaux projets locaux en
dehors des normes actuelles merci pour
votre témoignage toute dernière
intervention monsieur et nous passons à
la deuxième table ronde
merci Pierre Grosjean donc maire d'une
commune de 1700 habitants dans le Cher
donc comme une nouvelle moi je voudrais
juste témoigner vous avez vraiment enfin
c'est formidable de participer à cette
réunion quand on est un convaincu comme
moi de du besoin de simplifier par
contre on passera pas par les préfets
par les ABF moi je vais vous témoigner
d'une chose on a depuis plusieurs
préfets successifs préfectait préfet des
gens dans le Cher qui viennent à la
rencontre sur le terrain il y a pas de
souci on a une ABS qui vient quand elle
est avec nous sur un bâtiment quand le
préfet est avec nous pour modifier le
cheminement d'un d'un chemin rural dans
dans une zone d'activité le bon sens
prend le dessus mais lorsque ces
personnes rentrent dans leur château
avec leurs services avec toute cette
inertie administrative qui elle est en
place les préfets changent tous les deux
ans mais l'administration
local reste en place et bien ils en
reviennent malheureusement au texte et
au texte seulement vous pouvez avoir une
ABS et je fais un cas très simple qui
d'embourge va vous dire cette cheminée
là qui a été mal refaite avec du ciment
qui n'est plus en brique et qui penche
on la démonte elle sert plus à rien
puisqu'on a pas le droit de faire de feu
dans dans les on a plus le droit de
faire de feu de bois dans nos dans nos
villes et puis quand elle revient et
vous avez deux jours après un mail qui
vous dit qu'il faut la remonter à
l'identique historique comme la cheminée
comme elle était avant voilà donc je
pense que demander au préfet de se
mettre en risque peut-être mais ça
suffit pas il faut pousser très fort
l'administration en acier qui régit un
petit peu toute la mise en application
de ces normes
merci Monsieur le Maire donc vous
plaidez quelque part pour une thérapie
de choc madame Gatel nous entamons la
deuxième table ronde sur justement cette
thérapie de choc que le Sénat préconise
travers les propositions formulées dans
le rapport qu'avec monsieur Cointreau
vous avez présenté fin janvier quels
sont les lignes de force et les
principales propositions de ce rapport
merci tout en m'efforçant d'être brève
je voudrais répondre à Madame la
Directrice générale des services qu'elle
a totalement raison mais il nous semble
que il faut que les uns les autres ont
se cultive à la sobriété de la norme et
que dans les écoles où on forme nos
excellents fonctionnaires et je regarde
monsieur Gérard qui a été directeur de
Léna je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
apprenne aux fonctionnaires la sobriété
et la pertinence de de la norme c'est
alors 3DS excusez-moi je parle aussi au
nom de mon complice Mathieu larnault
parce que nous étions un peu à la barre
sur ce texte et si ce texte
euh cher madame vous semble plein
d'ampleur c'est parce que nous nous
sommes engouffrés dans un véhicule que
le gouvernement apportait quitter d'une
légèreté qui frôlait l'inconsistance
parce que nous avions beaucoup de choses
à mettre pour libérer les choses donc je
ne je ne pleure pas de coupable mais
j'assume ce travail que nous aurions
voulu pousser jusqu'à la lettre E qui
était celle de l'efficacité alors pour
revenir à ce que nous disions alors je
voudrais vous rassurer parmi les
sponsors de cette journée il n'y a pas
le Canard Enchaîné mais je vous invite
et je remercie David lisna qui m'a
apporté le Canard Enchaîné qui parle
agression d'émissions c'est pas la fête
des mères et que il parle d'un sujet qui
participe fortement à la démission de
932 depuis 2020 c'est le poids des
normes et les migraines que vous avez à
conjuguer l'impossible alors nous allons
marqué la deuxième table ronde et cela a
été dit on a diagnostiqué on connaît un
peu les remèdes et donc nous ce que nous
avons proposé avec Rémi Pointreau ça
n'est pas de renoncer au stock mais
surtout de dire comment pouvons-nous
empêcher ce que j'appelle l'accident
industriel qui empêche les mères de fer
et donc vous l'avez dit et David Lisnard
il le dit régulièrement avant nous
regardions ce qui était interdit
aujourd'hui on regarde ce qui est
empêché et sincèrement je le dis et même
le Canard Enchaîné le lit aujourd'hui
dans la fragilité de l'engagement et les
démissions jamais vu du nombre d'élus
locaux il y a
cette épuisement des élus face à cette
complexité qui n'est pas que complexité
qui est complication vous avez raison et
qui empêchement de faire donc nous nous
avons essayé de nous dire comment
peut-on fabriquer une loi
plus pert moins débordante d'aberration
et qui surtout qui évitent les
croisements de normes de normes
contradictoires et donc nous nous
pensons et au Sénat nous en serions
heureux plutôt que de nous épuiser à
simplifier
apostériori des normes déjà un produit
et surtout à passer beaucoup de temps à
faire des lois de guérison des irritants
on va parler de d'engagement et
proximité on va parler de la PPL sur
Lausanne aujourd'hui si on pouvait
éviter de s'irriter et donc de guérir en
produisant mieux et bien nous serions
très contents donc nous nous préconisons
des solutions simples sans se renchères
de normes et sans inventions de
disposition législatives nous allons
comment faire une maille en loi d'abord
donner au Parlement plus de visibilité
sur les textes envisagés par le
gouvernement dans le domaine des
collectivités locales des textes qui
nous arrivent un peu par surprise parce
qu'il y aurait urgent qui n'ont pas été
en amont concerté vraiment avec les
associations des lieux où le Parlement
se termine toujours mal et donc nous
nous suggérons qu'au début de à chaque
début de session le Gouvernement
présente au Sénat rapport d'orientation
présentant les principaux projets de
normes et qui vont impacter les
collectivités qui sont envisagées de
l'année pour l'année et nous proposons
qu'il y a un débat au Sénat en séance
publique ce qui permet au gouvernement
de prendre la température un peu de
notre adhésion ou des complexités la
deuxième piste porte sur les études
d'impact
les études d'impact elles existent dans
la loi le CNN a été créé pour mesurer
les les impacts pour les collectivités
or nous avons des outils que nous
n'utilisons pas et les études d'impact
qui sont produits qui sont présentés au
cnen elles sont souvent
assez légères ne comporte pas d'éléments
financiers que et je lis avec beaucoup
de respect madame la secrétaire général
je suis combien du gouvernement de
combien nous travaillons bien ensemble
mais en même temps force et de
reconnaître que les études d'impact qui
mesurent les conséquences pour nos
collectivités sont produites par les
services du ministère qui prônent la loi
donc la neutralité l'objectivité ne sont
pas tout à fait garanties et donc nous
nous demandons que l'étude d'impact
elle n'est pas forcément à être produite
de la manière dont on la connaît mais
que quand le gouvernement dit il faut
que je réforme que je révise
l'organisation territoriale ou telle ou
telle disposition nous nous souhaitons
qu'il y a une étude d'options qui
existent déjà dans la loi c'est-à-dire
que l'état des montres la nécessité de
produire une nouvelle norme et une
nouvelle loi
l'étude d'option elle existe mais elle
est rarement pratiquée ce qui veut dire
que nous aurions une nouvelle loi si
nous avions bien pris le temps
d'examiner que la qualité de la loi
n'est pas n'est pas suffisant enfin donc
nous proposons que les études d'impact
fassent l'objet d'une certification
quant à leur sincérité leur objectif et
leur complétude et pour ce faire nous ne
préconisons pas des recours à des
cabinets extérieurs nous l'avons c'est
le cnen et je regarde mon collègue à nos
voisins le CNEM à toute la compétence la
capacité si on veut bien lui donner des
moyens comme son équivalent allemand
a les moyens enfin troisième piste
pourquoi pourrions-nous depuis Paris un
beau matin de mars trouver le Graal de
l'efficacité de l'action publique je
prends l'exemple de la loi nôtre pour ne
pas être désagréable
ici on nous a expliqué un moment que
l'efficacité de l'interco était à partir
de 5000 habitants 5000 vous savez pas
4499 ça marche pas 51 c'est formidable 5
ans après non c'est 20 000 et comme ça
c'est pas on est descendu à 15000 et
comme 15000 ça passe pas partout on a
fait une série d'exceptions qui montre
que la règle elle ne tient pas et que
donc nous nous proposons
l'expérimentation
c'est comme un procès industriel vous
faites un prototype on fait une
expérimentation on évalue et on regarde
et nous proposons ce que les Anglais
appellent sunset low et qu'en France on
appelle la mot beaucoup plus fort qui
nous est à comprendre c'est la clause
guillotine
et alors la clause guillotine elle fait
aussi peur que celle qui coupait les
têtes c'est à dire on dit on adopte une
loi ou une âme pour une durée de 4 ou 5
ans au bout de quatre ou cinq ans cette
disposition tombe dès lors qu'on ne l'a
pas confirmé qu'on ne l'a pas réévalué
oui c'est comme un garde-fou qu'on se
met pour garantir que la fabrique de la
loi va être aussi on va dire rigoureuse
et de qualité que cela
et ce tableau je l'ai dit je crois que
le NKR allemand qui est l'équivalent
bénéficie de 25 personnes voilà le cneen
est assez remarquable et performant
parce qu'ils sont nos bases enfin ils
peuvent quand même atteindre la deuxième
main mais ils ne sont que 6 et nous nous
pensons que le Seigneur doit aussi être
entendu plus fréquemment à la délégation
mais dans les commissions concernées et
nous souhaitons que quand le CNN émet un
avis négatif il y est obligatoirement
une révision de la proposition du
gouvernement qui est une deuxième
délibération vous savez que sur les
décrets d'application d'usane le cnen a
aimé un avis négatif mais la machine a
continué sa route et enfin nous
proposons de créer au Sénat une fonction
de veille et d'alerte au niveau des
commissions permanentes parce que dans
les commissions aux affaires économiques
aménagement et développement durable où
mes collègues font un excellent travail
vous prenez des dispositions économiques
qui viennent impacter les collectivités
territoriales or aujourd'hui on n'est
pas en capacité de mesurer ses effets
parce que tout ça va très vite et nous
nous pensons que la fonction de veille
et d'alerte sera
vraiment d'une grande efficacité donc je
n'en dirai pas plus
pour laisser la place à nos éminents
intervenants universitaires président
adjoint du Conseil d'État et Arnaud
Bazin qui représente le président
merci merci Madame Gatel vous avez cité
à plusieurs reprises le cnen nous allons
écouter son président Alain Lambert qui
est empêché aujourd'hui mais qui a
enregistré un petit message à
l'attention des participants si la régie
peut lancer cette vidéo merci
bonjour à tous je suis sincèrement
désolé de ne pouvoir être parmi vous
mais que voulez-vous la médecine dans a
décidé autrement mais bravo au Sénat
bravo au président Gérard Larcher
d'avoir organisé ces étages généraux
vous savez la simplification est un
objectif qui est partagé par tous et
pourtant elle nous apparaît inaccessible
et pourtant elle ne dépend que de nous
nous avons tendance à en faire porter la
responsabilité sur les autres alors que
chacun d'entre nous y contribue plus ou
moins
c'est la faute des gouvernements certes
mais le droit s'appliquant collectivités
territoriales et presque intégralement
du domaine de la loi et personne ne
force le Parlement à l'adopter dans ses
excès c'est la faute des technocrate
certes mais sans faire erreur ils
agissent bien sous l'autorité de
ministres lesquels pourraient les
soumettre au principe de réalité du
terrain c'est la faute des amendements
parlementaires certes mais pourquoi
personne n'invoque l'irres solvabilité
qui serait opposable dans la majorité
des cas alors est-ce la faute des
collectivités territoriales qui parfois
réclament elle-même des textes pour se
couvrir on voit bien que la traduction à
la dorme et à la complexité et
partiellement aussi notre responsabilité
voilà pourquoi cette rencontre
d'aujourd'hui est utile elle doit être
l'occasion d'un échange direct concret
franc et sincère entre nous pour
examiner le plus concrètement possible
chacun notre place ce que nous pouvons
faire pour briser ce fléau de la
complexité en cessant de le croire
fatale il ne dépend que de nous de le
conjuguer et je ne doute pas que vous
serez adopté des mesures fortes pour
faire percer le rayon de soleil dans
l'action publique a besoin et ce rayon
de soleil soleil pardon s'appelle la
simplification
voilà
le rayon de soleil c'est la
simplification le Sénat fait des
propositions pour que nous allions vers
la simplification je vais demander à
Arnaud Bazin sénateur du Val-d'Oise
membre du Conseil national d'évaluation
des normes de réagir aux propositions
rappelées par Madame Gatel qui notamment
prône un renforcement des moyens et du
niveau d'intervention du Conseil
national et puis peut-être y ajouterez
vous quelques autres propositions au nom
du CNN qui vient de rendre d'ailleurs
son rapport d'activité
2019-2022 nous vous écoutons je suis
désolé nous sommes aussi contraints pour
la première table ronde vous avez quatre
petites minutes merci à vous et bien on
va te faire très rapidement quelques
éléments de diagnostic puisque le
président lombaire vient de s'exprimer
et il n'a pas eu le temps certainement
dans le temps imparti de dire que
lui-même est le CNN déplore
la perte de qualité du droit aussi et
cette perte de qualité c'est pas un
hasard elle est associée à
empoisonnement de ce droit dont on a eu
plusieurs exemples tout à l'heure je ne
vais pas vous perdre dans les chiffres
mais le nombre de lois promulgués a subi
une augmentation de 161% en 20 ans quant
aux ordonnances on est à 758%
d'augmentation voilà donc foisonnement
perte de qualité d'où évidemment
complexité les charges on en a dit un
mot tout à l'heure 2 milliards et demi
pour les collectivités territoriales en
2022 contre moins de 800 millions en
2019 donc là il y a une véritable
trajectoire et enfin dernier symptôme
les procédures exceptionnelles que nous
apprécions beaucoup au cnen 23%
d'urgence et d'extrême urgence sur les
textes examinés en 2022 conduit pour
cent en 2019 alors une procédure
d'urgence ou d'extrême urgence aussi
annuel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
concrètement ça veut dire que moi membre
du cnen je reçois un mail l'après-midi
pour me dire que si je n'ai pas réagi le
lendemain à midi la proposition sera
considérée comme entériner
bon
nous avons une certaine notion de notre
engagement vis-à-vis du CN mais c'est
pas toujours facile concrètement à
mettre en oeuvre pour prendre les
contacts nécessaires et puis tout
simplement réfléchir à la situation faut
être clair donc ça le président Lambert
le dénonce régulièrement les procédures
d'urgence et d'extrême urgence qui
foisonnent dans ces conditions c'est
insupportable c'est incompatible avec
notre mission voilà quelques éléments
très rapides du diagnostic pour
compléter tout ce qui a été justement
dit jusque là sur les propositions du
Sénat que vient d'évoquer
Françoise Gatel évidemment nous les
suivons la question est de se concentrer
aujourd'hui sur le flux nous avons aussi
à la mission du CA au cnen la mission de
traiter le stock malheureusement nous ne
le pouvons pas vous l'avez certainement
deviné à travers les quelques chiffres
que je vous ai donné à l'instant donc
oui travaillons en priorité sur la
question du flux de texte de les rendre
en effet plus compatible avec
l'efficacité
le notre équivalent allemand qui est
mieux de techno Françoise Gatel l'a
rappelé a aussi la possibilité
d'entendre les le gouvernement sur le
contenu de la loi l'idée de ce qu'on
veut faire avant même de nous
transmettre des textes normatifs on se
met d'accord et sans effet l'idée de le
faire à travers un débat avec le
Parlement paraît tout à fait pertinente
c'est une idée qu'il faut suivre qu'on
sache de quoi on parle et ensuite les
techniciens les légistes mettent ça dans
la forme qui va bien mais il faut
absolument qu'on soit au contact de la
réalité au départ de la conception c'est
ce que c'est ce que disent les élus
locaux bien sûr la question des études
d'impact est tout à fait cruciale il
faut de l'évaluation excentée et expost
comme disent nos technocrates favoris
dans la moitié des cas en 2020 des
études d'impact qui ont été transmises
au cnen la fiche financière était
insuffisamment renseignée et ne
permettait pas ou ne permett pas du tout
d'ailleurs d'avoir une
appréhension des conséquences
financières tout ça se fait par la suite
plus ou moins bien donc il faut
absolument que ces études d'impact
progressent en qualité et que la fiche
financière soit systématiquement
renseigné ensuite il nous faut pouvoir
avoir des vérifications sur tout ça
c'est-à-dire des de l'évaluation
postérieure et pour ça il serait utile
que le cnen puisse travailler de façon
organisée avec l'Insee qu'à tous les
moyens nécessaires pour qu'on va pas
reconstituer d'autres moyens
d'investigation mais en effet un
partenariat entre le cnen et l'INC
pourrait être tout à fait utile afin de
dévaluer ce que nous avons fait la
question des études d'option évidemment
nous la suivons complètement il est
indispensable qu'on puisse avoir sur la
table l'évaluation de ce qui se produit
si on adopte cette norme de ce qui se
passe aussi si on ne l'adopte pas et
puis enfin quels sont éventuellement les
autres possibilités avant de décider ça
renvoie à aussi cette notion d'avoir une
bonne idée du contenu avant de décider
modalités voilà quelques éléments qui me
paraissent tout à fait essentiel étant
entendu que ce qu'il nous faut aussi
restaurer c'est un lien de confiance
entre l'État le gouvernement et le
Parlement et entre le Parlement qui
produit la norme et les collectivités si
on ne restaure pas ce lien de confiance
on va être en permanence dans ce qui a
été décrit tout à l'heure et ayant été
maire pendant 16 ans j'avais aussi
quelques exemples délicieux mais il y en
a eu tellement que je vais gérer ma
frustration mais sinon on va rester dans
cette situation et en effet c'est la
confiance qu'il faut absolument
restaurer et le cnen peut être un des
lieux avec l'ensemble des propositions
qui ont été évoquées pour restaurer
cette confiance voilà j'ai essayé d'être
bref merci beaucoup
on constate à ce stade une convergence
dans les propositions du Sénat et du CNE
la feuille de route que le gouvernement
présenterait au Parlement sur ces textes
impactant les collectivités locales le
renforcement des études d'impact en
amont et en aval excenté exposte de ses
normes la création de de cette option
qui consisterait avoir sur une norme est
vraiment justifiée et si elle l'est à
renforcer son instruction et sa
certification par le CNN voilà quelques
propositions que l'on voit et puis
madame Gatel on pourrait aussi ajouter
deux propositions la première c'est que
le gouvernement prendra un collectif
budgétaire dans la foulée d'un texte
impactant les collectivités locales ce
qui n'est pas le cas souvent une réforme
est prise et le volet financière envoyé
à une loi de finances quelques mois plus
tard quand le divolet est bien abordé
par la loi de finances et la deuxième
chose c'est le renforcement du rôle
pédagogique dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure des préfets c'est la création de
cet instance autour du préfet associant
préfet élu et qui se pencherait sur une
interprétation divergente d'une norme le
rôle pour le préfet consistant à poser
la position de l'État et la règle qui
devrait être suivie mais encore
faudrait-il que les préfets c'est
engagent ne craignent pas trop de
contentieux voilà je passe la parole
maintenant à Olivier renaudy vous êtes
professeur de droit public à la Sorbonne
et vous allez nous livrer votre
appréciation des propositions tendues
Sénat que du cnewn nous vous écoutons
pour trois quatre minutes s'il vous
plaît
merci merci madame la Présidente pour
votre invitation trois observations
liminaires première observation cette
question de la simplification des normes
c'est une question ancienne déjà par
exemple en 1977 le doyen Savatier
pouvait écrire un article intitulé
l'inflation législative et l'indigestion
du corps social cette indigestion il en
a été largement en question il en a été
question également dans les propos et
les exemples des élus locaux deuxième
observation je partage la perception des
élus locaux à propos des normes les
concernant et au fond de type de
problème d'un côté des normes trop
nombreuses et qui change trop
fréquemment ce qui provoque l'insécurité
juridique et puis de l'autre des normes
trop volumineuses trop touffus ce qui
suscite la complexité le législateur
semble avoir de la peine à écrire
simplement tout autant qu'il semble
avoir de la peine à ne pas assortir de
multiples exceptions les principes qu'il
formule ce qui provoque l'exaspération
de la population ce qui provoque le
bonheur des consultants en droit
troisième observation la délégation aux
collectivités à raison de se pencher sur
ce sujet aujourd'hui car cela a déjà été
dit mais elle va devoir faire face à un
défi majeur comment développer la
différenciation territoriale qu'elle
appelle de ses vœux sans que cela
conduise à la complexification du droit
applicable au collectivité alors comment
précisément simplifier les normes
applicables aux collectivités c'est à
cette question d'ampleur que sa tâche le
rapport qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
j'ai avec ce rapport beaucoup de points
d'accord et une interrogation commençons
par le plus important les points
d'accord je suis d'accord avec les
principales propositions de ce rapport
première proposition qui consiste à
donner plus de visibilité sur les textes
envisagés par le gouvernement dans le
domaine des collectivités cette
proposition elle est de bon sens elle
est facile à mettre en œuvre et il n'y a
pas besoin de normes juridiques pour la
mettre en oeuvre peut-être cependant que
l'on s'expose à une difficulté qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'une norme qui est en
rapport avec les collectivités d'un côté
il y a des textes qui concerne très
directement les collectivités et cela
ils sont très faciles à identifier mais
aujourd'hui pour n'importe quel norme
dans n'importe quel politique publique
et les exemples qui ont été pris l'ont
bien attesté il y a toujours quelques
dispositions qui concernent les
collectivités est-ce que cela rentre
dans le champ de cette disposition ou
pas et le champ de cette proposition
pouvant varier à mon avis c'est son
intérêt aussi qui peut être questionné
la seconde proposition elle concerne
l'évaluation des normes d'un côté le
rapport à parfaitement raison de faire
de l'évaluation un outil pour lutter
contre la complexité des normes
applicables aux collectivités
aujourd'hui l'évaluation est présente
deux défauts majeurs d'un côté et ça
fait consensus les études d'impact sont
de qualité inégale et puis de l'autre
l'évaluation expost et délaissés
s'agissant des études d'impact
aujourd'hui on doit faire le constat en
effet elles sont malheureusement des
exposés des motifs consolidés et
déguisés et la proposition qui consiste
à recommander au gouvernement d'élaborer
une étude d'options on ne peut qui
souscrire elle est aussi plutôt facile à
mettre en oeuvre dans le cadre de la loi
organique et c'est très bien mais enfin
est-ce que la question n'est pas de
savoir qui tient la plume comment au
fond demander à celui qui est convaincu
de la nécessité d'un texte au point
d'avoir formalisé un projet de loi sur
le sujet d'étudier sérieusement les
autres options possibles y compris
l'absence d'action et l'absence de texte
s'agissant de l'évaluation expo il y a
sur ce sujet je crois en France un
problème culturel en raison de notre
législantisme nous sommes persuadés
qu'une fois votée la loi est parée de
toutes les vertus il convient donc de
développer les expérimentations il
convient donc de développer les clauses
expérimentales les clauses de revoyure
qui permettent de faire le point
quelques années après sur l'intérêt de
la disposition de ce point de vue madame
la Présidente je ne peux pas ne pas vous
dire de ne pas hésiter à solliciter les
universitaires les laboratoires de
recherche nous sommes beaucoup moins
chers que les cabinets d'avant de
conseils et nous avons de l'expertise en
économie en finance en droit n'hésitez
pas à nous solliciter pour procéder à
ces expérimentations
il y a beaucoup de points d'accord et
puis il y a une petite incompréhension
je termine par là s'agissant de de mon
point de vue sur ce rapport au fond dans
ce rapport il est dressé le portrait
chinois de l'organisme ou de
l'institution qui pourrait
œuvrer à la simplification des normes
applicable au collectivités qui
pourraient porter cette thérapie de
short que vous appelez de vos vœux cette
organisme doit être indépendant
il doit bien connaître les collectivités
territoriales
il doit être familier de l’écriture des
normes
il doit être compétent en matière
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
il doit disposer de moyens financiers
matériels et humains
cet organisme de mon point de vue ce
n'est pas le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes aussi
remarquables soit son travail
cette organisme c'est le Sénat
c'est au Sénat qu'il revient d'être
l'acteur majeur de la simplification
cette au Sénat qu'il revient de prendre
la main
à moyen constant et organisation
constante ou bien encore sous la forme
de la création d'un office parlementaire
pour être l'acteur majeur de cette
simplification
merci ça tombe bien le Sénat
une fusion Sénat CNL en tout cas c'est
le Sénat qui signera la charte
d'engagement tout à l'heure avec le
gouvernement donc qui est bien chef de
fil sur ce sujet dernière intervention
de la matinée Patrick Gérard président
adjoint de la section de
l'administration du Conseil d'État
monsieur Gérard vous allez revenir sur
cette fonction consultative du Conseil
d'État qu'on connaît peu sauf quand on
en est membre et deuxièmement vous aviez
réalisé en 2016 une étude annuelle qui
portait sur la simplification qui qui
s'appelait très exactement
simplification et qualité du droit et
dans cette étude annuelle vous formuliez
aussi des propositions lors de la
simplification normative et donc nous
croiserons les principales de vos
propositions à l'époque avec celle que
Madame Gatel a fait je vous passe la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur je
remercie madame la présidente Françoise
guettel et monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président de la délégation de
d'inviter le Conseil d'État de cette
session d'aujourd'hui d'abord pour vous
dire que nous sommes évidemment
conscients de cette inflation normative
qui est terrible nous sommes conscients
parce que c'est une inflation qui a des
risques pour la cohésion de la société
si la loi n'est plus compréhensible que
comment demander des citoyens d'adhérer
à quelque chose nous sommes conscients
de ces inconvénients pour la
compétitivité du pays
parce que si les normes sont compliqués
c'est très difficile de venir et
investir et nous sommes conscients aussi
de cette complexité pour ceux qui ont à
les faire vivre et en particulier les
élus locaux dont on comprend bien que
certains sont là d'avoir des injonctions
contradictoires il y a d'ailleurs au
Conseil d'État des locaux j'en ai été un
nous avons actuellement le maire
d'Olivier le maire de Bourg-en-Bresse
qui sont parmi nos membres et donc nous
sommes extrêmement sensibles à tout à
tous ces sujets je rappelle simplement
que la norme c'est quand même la
traduction d'une politique publique s'il
y a des normes c'est parce qu'il y a des
politiques publiques et quand vous avez
des élections présidentielles vous avez
11 candidats chacun vous propose une
liste de promesses qui vont toutes se
traduire par des normes et je vois mal
un candidat qui serait élu et qui a dit
c'est voté pour moi je ne ferai rien
donc il y aura toujours des normes et on
peut pas imaginer que on vive on vive ça
mais il faut éviter il faut éviter
l'addiction alors le rôle du Conseil
d'État qui examine à peu près 1000
textes par an dans un projet de loi
projet d'ordonnance quelquefois
proposition de loi du Parlement
proposition loi du pays
Nouvelle-Calédonie des projets de décret
c'est d'abord de veiller à la rédaction
le choix des mots la clarté le plan des
textes le respect des règles supérieures
pour un décret les lois ou les principes
généraux du droit c'est un décret
autonome pour une loi les traitée la
Constitution
tout ça est pareil parait normal et puis
de se prononcer sur l'opportunité
administrative et je dois dire que
là-dessus nous sommes extrêmement
sensibles d'abord à l'étude d'impact et
il arrive très souvent en Conseil d'État
dans les avis sur les projets de loi qui
sont liés rendus publics après le
conseil ministre de dire au gouvernement
qu'il faut améliorer l'étude d'impact
entre le moment où nous l'avons lu et
nous l'avons trouvé quelquefois
insuffisante et le moment elle doit être
présentée au Conseil des ministres nous
le faisons et nous le lisons assez
souvent nous sommes aussi extrêmement
sensibles aux avis du cnen et lorsque le
CEL donne des avis réservés ou négatifs
nous essayons d'en tenant compte
est-ce que nos propositions que nous
avons faites en 2016 et juste celle du
monsieur Touboul qui était des auteurs
de ce rapport
rejoignent celle du CNL en très grande
partie oui d'abord l'affaire de
l'évaluation je l'ai dit il faut que les
textes soient mieux évalués mais pas
seulement les projets de loi
parce qu'il y a des projets de loi au
départ et puis il y a la loi la sortie
et puis entre le projet de loi au départ
et la loi assortie il y a les
amendements du Gouvernement et les
amendements parlementaires et ni les
amendements du Gouvernement ni les
amendements parlementaires ne
connaissent études impact et donc il
faut sans doute ils sont j'ai je pense
que on pourrait faire de même d'ailleurs
pour les propositions de loi
deuxièmement il faut mieux répartir les
compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales nous l'avons
dit dans plusieurs rapports et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore
beaucoup de confusion troisièmement il y
a l'étude de l'option 0 qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si on ne faisait rien est-ce
qu'il faut toujours une loi je prends
l'exemple des excès de vitesse sur la
route est-ce qu'il faut encore une loi
ou est-ce qu'il faut pas simplement
mettre plus de radar il y a des choses
qu'on peut faire sans faire de la norme
et on a toujours cette culture
effectivement professeur Renaud dit
parlait de ce qu'il écrivait doyen
Savatier 1977 je pourrais monter au
comte d'Argenton du temps le week-end
qui disait déjà ce pays fait trop de
normes donc c'est un c'est une maladie
française
encore que rassurons-nous nous nous ne
sommes pas un pays fédéral et donc quand
vous avez les pays fédéraux vous avez la
norme locale la norme de l'État et la
norme de l'État fédéral c'est
quelquefois plus compliqué que chez nous
aussi et donc l'option du moratoire qui
est une option qui est
presque l'option 0 ou l'option de la
clause guillotine que vous proposez nous
paraissent des
idées tout à fait intéressantes que nous
avions nous-mêmes
énoncés et puis il y a l'évaluation
postériori est-ce que on veut regarder
on a fait il y a quelques années une
grande revue générale des politiques
publiques pour les dépenses budgétaires
on fait jamais sur les lois est-ce que
on pourrait faire à la revue générale de
la révision des normes et voir ce qui se
passe et enfin je voudrais vous dire que
le Conseil d'État reste très attaché à
ce sujet nous sortirons notre rapport
annuel nous publierons au mois de
septembre 2023 et il s'appellera les
politiques publiques jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre et donc nous sommes en train
de réfléchir de façon approfondie avec
beaucoup et notamment avec les élus
locaux et notamment avec le cnen à la
façon dont on peut améliorer tout ça
merci beaucoup pour votre intervention
[Musique]
et ce que vous venez de dire c'est
typiquement révélateur de cela donc que
la Grande Chambre des communes de France
Quel Sénat nettoie tout ça ça me va très
bien voilà je vais pas être plus précis
que là ce serait inconvenant d'aller
plus loin
merci réaction commentaire et peut-être
autre proposition dans la salle madame
je vous demanderai de vous présenter
s'il vous plaît Françoise je suis lu au
conseil municipal de Bougival dans les
Yvelines et je suis par ailleurs
médiateur devant les juridictions
administratives
et donc c'est surtout en tant que
médiateur que je voudrais dire quelques
mots alors par rapport à ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure je voudrais dire que
depuis une loi de 2016 le code de
justice administrative développe un site
à développer la médiation devant les
juridictions administratives notamment
alors pour rejoindre ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure je voudrais dire la
difficulté que nous avons à mettre en
place ces médiations quand nous sommes
désignés par un tribunal ou une cour
d'appel parce que justement comme la
réglementation est très complexe on ne
sait pas toujours qui on doit faire
venir en médiation du côté de
l'administration est-ce que c'est un
représentant du ministère d'un ministère
d'une région d'un département est-ce que
c'est le maire local sachant qu'il y a
souvent un partage de compétences
alors là où on est heureux c'est quand
on arrive à avoir les différents
interlocuteurs qui acceptent de venir
devant le médiateur là on est vraiment
très contents et je voudrais souligner
le rôle important que joue les maires
quand il viennent dans les admis dans
les enfin dans les médiations parce que
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit le
maire à ce moment-là se retrouve souvent
face à un ou plusieurs administrés moi
je fais beaucoup de dossiers d'urbanisme
je suis beaucoup saisie en matière
d'urbanisme et très souvent il y a une
démarche pédagogique que le maire peut à
ce moment-là faire face à leurs
administes à ses administrés qui n'ont
pas toujours compris la réglementation
les réglementations qui s'appliquent à
eux et là c'est assez impressionnant et
il y a même dans certains cas des
représentants du préfet qui viennent en
médiation et ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment à développer parce que on
beaucoup de problèmes je peux vous
assurer alors on simplifie pas la loi on
élute pas les normes mais il y a une
démarche de communication une démarche
d'écoute et c'est très important vous
participez à votre niveau aussi à la
compréhension et l'appréhension par les
élus locaux du droit ah oui oui en plus
oui oui puisque dans ma commune je fais
partie de la commission urbanisme donc
c'est c'est vraiment important
réaction Marie-Claude Jaro merde
c'est une bonne proposition madame mais
ça prend au maire beaucoup beaucoup de
temps il ne faut préparer le dossier
nous approprier le préparer puis ensuite
conduire avec vous la médiation c'est
c'est à la limite de ce que nous pouvons
faire parce que nous sommes extrêmement
sollicités sur de nombreux sujets et moi
je j'ai une réserve quand au temps que
nous devons passer sur sur ces sur ce
problème là
si je peux vous répondre effectivement
ça prend du temps mais j'ai toujours
rencontré beaucoup de bonnes volonté de
la part des élus ah mais c'est vraiment
je les en remercie j'en doute pas mais
c'est quand même extrêmement chronophage
pour nous
merci là on touche aussi à la
compréhension à l'appréhension du du
droit madame Gatel dans vos propositions
vous proposez justement de renforcer
aussi à la fois la formation
des fonctionnaires de l'administration
centrale la formation à la
simplification non pas la
complexification et également de
renforcer le rôle du préfet du
sous-préfet en la matière ça ça n'existe
pas du tout aujourd'hui il y a plus
aucune action si tant et qui en ait une
un jour pédagogique de la part du préfet
des services des concentrés pour
expliquer aux élus la norme alors de
répondre je voudrais monsieur le
professeur saluait la confiance que vous
avez
dans le Sénat et que je partage votre
attente d'une exigence de la part du
snack c'est pourquoi nous avons évoqué
parler évoluent une fonction de veille
et d'alerte
en amont tous les textes qui soient
poreuses si je puis dire parce que vous
l'avez dit professeur vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président adjoint
nous avons un vrai sujet c'est il y a
des tests des textes collectivités
territoriales donc c'est clair on sait
où on met vous prenez un texte climat et
résignant ce qui au départ forcément un
texte pour les collectivités
vous retrouvez une incidence alors là un
accident industriel le terrible avec le
Zam vous avez des normes sur
l'alimentation ou que sais-je vous allez
les retrouver dans l'action des
collectivités locales donc l'idée c'est
bien comment on s'imprègne du tout et
comment on trouve des solutions pour
faire et non pas pour faire et juste sur
le zanne aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on
à un moment on accusait le Sénat d'être
anti climatique si je puis dire en
disant le Sénat ne veut pas c'est pas ça
l'idée c'est que nous nous pensons que
un objectif de sobriété foncière pour
préserver notre agriculture et c'est
absolument nécessaire mais que pour
arriver à l'objectif il faut démonter la
mécanique et faire la norme après et
souvent ce qui se passe c'est au fait
une norme sans partir du besoin de
service qu'on a à rendre et sans
remonter les choses et puis nous nous
pensons effectivement ici nous défendons
le pouvoir réglementaire local du du
préfet pourquoi la vie elle ne s'enferme
pas et elle n'est pas sous vite ça veut
dire vous décidez d'une loi à un moment
et d'une norme ensuite au fil de l'eau
arrive des événements qui font que vous
devez avoir une appréciation
particulière et donc nous nous
souhaitons laisser au préfet la capacité
d'apprécier un moment pour adapter c'est
ainsi par exemple que dans la loi 3df
nous avons voulu porter et obtenu le
contrat de mixité sociale je vais
prendre l'exemple de la mère du Croisic
la mère du Croisic qui lui reste 8000 m²
de terrain qui lui appartiennent pas
pour construire elle a obligation de
faire des logements sociaux elle ne peut
plus les faire parce qu'elle n'a plus de
mètres carrés sauf que la loizanne
aujourd'hui ne lui permet pas d'avoir la
solution mais la loi srue s'applique
donc elle elle continue à payer des
amendes alors même qu'une autre loi
l'empêche de faire et que donc à un
moment il faut de l'intelligence du prêt
parce que je pense que la loi ne peut
pas tout porter en même temps la loi
pardonnez-moi n'est pas open bar nous
vivons dans un pays et dans une
démocratie où il faut des règles mais la
vie nous dépasse et la vie va plus vite
que nous c'est pour ça que la guillotine
pardonnez-moi
il fut un temps il fut un temps où elle
avait mauvaise réputation mais je pense
qu'ici enfin ici pardonnez-moi sur la
loi elle pourrait nous faire
suffisamment peur pour nous encourager à
plus de vert la clause guillotine
rappelons-le ça consisterait après une
évaluation à moyen terme d'une norme à
supprimer la dites norme si elle se
révèle inefficace c'est pire que ça
c'est à dire vous avez une annonce comme
une date limite de consommation si je
puis dire pour faire simple vous dites
cette loi on l'adopte aujourd'hui elle a
une durée de vie de 5 ou 6 ans ça veut
dire que si vous n'avez pas pensé à
checker tous les textes qui arrivent à
un moment voilà la guillotine arrive la
loi elle tombe je vous ai dit les
Anglais ils ont un mot merveilleux ils
parlent de Sunset
l'eau et le pire c'est que le coucher du
soleil c'est tous les jours vous voyez
nous nous sommes beaucoup plus raisonna
mais je pense que ça n'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga mais je pense qu'il ne faut
pas il ne faut pas se priver
d'éléments qui sont qui relèvent parfois
de la chirurgie quand l'homéopathie ne
suffit pas
merci Madame
votre bouton rouge
je suis étudiante en master Droit et
gestion publique à Dauphiné Elian SP et
donc d'abord je tenais à vous remercier
pour vos interventions qui ont été très
instructives et j'ai une petite question
Mesdames et Messieurs les maires ont
commencé leur intervention en parlant du
fait que le plus que la complexification
de la norme c'est la lenteur qu'elle
produit qui agace passablement les
citoyens et donc ma question porte sur
la recommandation numéro 2 donc faire
des études d'impact des études d'option
ensuite les certifiés respectivement
puis faire une expérimentation et le
mettre en place sur l'ensemble du
territoire est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur finalement que ça aussi ça
ralentisse le temps législatif ce qui
est du coup déjà une critique qui est
mise par les citoyens
être lent et inefficace
c'est un double péché si on est
peut-être un peu plus on prend du temps
parce qu'on réfléchit mais qu'on est sûr
d'être efficace ça peut nous être
pardonné par nos concitoyens
c'est une très bonne question mais
je pense que le temps de gestation de la
norme
c'est dans ce temps de gestation de la
langue qu'il faut faire les études
d'impact etc mais c'est pas ensuite dans
l'application de la nor et c'est dans
l'application de la norme qu'il faut
gagner du temps mais c'est ainsi qu'on
qu'on réunit les deux problématiques si
vous voulez travailler en amont et donc
déterminant madame et ensuite madame oui
allez-y
je vous remercie de m'accorder la parole
et merci d'ailleurs à toutes et à tous
d'avoir organisé ces états généraux moi
je suis doctorante en droit public
comparé à la Sorbonne et je fais une
thèse en légistique donc c'est tout ce
qui touche à la qualité du droit en
France et en Allemagne donc on est en
plein dans le sujet et j'ai beaucoup
écrit sur le NKR c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais rebondir sur sur vos propos
qui est le vrai faux homologue du CNN
français puisqu'en réalité ils ont pas
du tout les mêmes champs de compétences
ne serait-ce qu'en raison de la forme de
l'État qui est différente
premièrement et deuxièmement sur
concernant comment dire vis-à-vis du
fait quand en France le cnen travaille
essentiel exclusivement sur les normes
qui ont un impact sur les collectivités
territoriales
et j'ai alors l'impression qu'on
fantasme c'est souvent
la pratique allemande même si je salue
vraiment qu'on est évoqué des éléments
de droit comparé en la matière je pense
que c'est vraiment indispensable et
d'ailleurs il y a pas qu'en Allemagne au
niveau européen mondial que que des
organismes de
la même sorte de la même forme que le
CNN existe
j'ai l'impression que que la première
chose dont on pourrait s'inspirer
vraiment sur la pratique allemande dans
l'espèce c'est vraiment le la
coopération inter-institutionnelle et
au début j'ai découvert les au début de
ma thèse j'ai découvert l'existence du
cnen un peu par hasard sans vouloir
vexer personne d'ailleurs mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on que c'est une
institution vraiment à part qui
travaille beaucoup avec le Sénat
effectivement en Allemagne ils ont
vraiment cette force je crois déjà
d'être inscrit dans un projet
gouvernemental
qui s'appelle je vous la fait version
française mais des construction de la
bureaucratie et mieux légiférer donc ça
reprend même le vocabulaire de la
politique européenne en la matière
et un travail très étroit avec l'Office
fédéral de la statistique et je sais que
le président Lambert a beaucoup milité
on essaye encore il me semble
d'instaurer un lien entre le cneen et
l'INSEE et je pense que ça faciliterait
vraiment notamment le développement du
travail du contrôle des évaluations
expost qui à ce stade de son comme le
CNN l'explique très fréquemment
absolument impossible puisque déjà pour
le contrôle du flux donc ex hanté
on manque enfin il est elle manque de
moyens et de temps or je pense que ça
relève de l'évidence que tant qu'on
pourra pas pratiquer pardon le contrôle
expost pour se rendre compte de ce qui a
fonctionné ou pas excenté donc avant que
la norme soit mise en oeuvre en fait on
entretiendra une sorte de statu quo et
j'ai l'impression aussi je termine
rapidement que en France le comment dire
l'amalgame est fait assez fréquemment
avec l'évaluation des politiques
publiques et les deux se rejoignent je
suis juriste et pas politique donc c'est
plutôt vraiment l'aspect contrôle de la
norme qui m'intéresse mais je pense que
cette amalgamation cet amalgame pardon
des deux ne facilitent pas non plus une
lecture claire des outils qu'on a en la
matière j'avais je suis en train
d'oublier ce que je voulais si je
voulais rebondir sur les propos très
rapidement du du professeur renaudy
j'avais jamais envisagé effectivement le
fait de
d'accorder cette compétence au Sénat
plutôt qu'au CNN alors peut-être mon
côté un peu j'aime mes petites habitudes
donc je trouve ça quand même à mon avis
pertinent que le CN enfin qui est une
institution vraiment dédiée en fait
[Musique]
à tout ce qui touche à la qualité du
droit en l'espèce pour l'instant en
France peut-être que ça changera ça
concerne les normes applicable
collectivité
territorial et peut-être qu'à terme ça
pourrait en renforçant je sais pas le
travail avec le SGG aussi
ce que vous madame Gates je voulais
laisser répondre ce que vous proposez
aussi c'est peut-être l'élaboration de
ce fameux droit collaboratif entre
l'État et les le Parlement et le CNE
c'est vrai que ça on a l'impression
madame millatel que ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de de
coproduction du droit ou de la
réglementation de travail en bonne
intelligence c'est ce que nous
encourageons en tout cas que ce soit
moins
occasionnel
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez raison je
voudrais saluer la présence parmi nous
de Monsieur François Noël buffet
président de la commission
des lois du du Sénat qui souhaitera
peut-être intervenir tout à l'heure et
nous avons une demande de parole de
madame la secrétaire
général du gouvernement merci madame je
crois vous avoir vu de vous écoutons
merci beaucoup
trois mots d'abord j'étais
essentiellement là pour écouter et j'ai
trouvé ça pas étonnant merci beaucoup de
votre invitation on a l'occasion
d'échanger régulièrement sur sur ces
sujets qui sont je crois et c'est une
des vraiment des très bonnes nouvelles
de ce colloque font l'objet d'un constat
qui est partagé et j'ai trouvé que les
propos d'Alain Lambert sur la
responsabilité collective et le
l'importance de pas se renvoyer la balle
est très importante parce qu'on a tous
On a tous une part à jouer dans cette
affaire peut-être que je vais me
permettre de dire deux trois choses sur
ce que je trouve quand même positif dans
un contexte dont on sait que
l'accélération par exemple du temps et
du coup les recours la consultation en
urgence du cnen mais du Conseil d'État
la production en temps très contraint
c'est un peu c'est pas propre à la pro
normative à vrai dire c'est c'est les
réseaux sociaux la pression médiatique
il y a beaucoup de choses qui nous
contraignent à travailler très vite et
qui rendent plus compliqué encore ce
qu'on souhaite faire d'avoir le temps de
se poser avant de prendre des décisions
mais il y a aussi des choses qui
progressent grâce à des outils modernes
par exemple le numérique fait que
l'accessibilité de la norme est quand
même c'est à la fois je pense le
numérique parfois un
accélérateur de production parce que ça
facilite la production dramatique d'une
certaine façon mais c'est aussi une
capacité d'accès qui s'améliore et ça
c'est quand même une bonne chose il y a
les outils modernes Légifrance mais il y
a aussi la codification dont on n'a pas
du tout parlé mais qui est qui sont des
choses importantes moi je partage je
crois aussi par donc dans les constats
positifs cette culture du dernier
kilomètre alors le Conseil d'État a
repris ce on va pas dire ce slogan mais
parfois c'est ça peut paraître un peu
comme elle en tout cas ça change les
choses et la culture du résultat qui se
substitue à la culture de la norme c'est
quelque chose auquel le président est
très attaché qu'il rappelle
régulièrement et c'est un des un des
objectifs de de l'identificat
l'identification des politiques
prioritaires du gouvernement a sorti
d'indicateurs où on regarde d'abord
comment ça marche sur le terrain pour
faire éventuellement remonter un besoin
de simplification plutôt que de se
lancer dans des grands exercices de
simplification tous azimut dont on a vu
qu'il pouvait être finalement
contre-productif
peut-être juste sur deux points un peu
plus particuliers sur les
sunset close on a eu l'occasion d'en
expérimenter dans certaines législations
moi je pense parce que il se trouve que
j'y ai pas mal travaillé au droit du
renseignement par exemple où on s'est
dit on essaye pendant 5 ans puisse
attendre l'expérience fait aussi que on
se rend compte que parfois du coup on
légifère plusieurs fois pour
soit pérenniser ce qui est d'une
certaine façon un mode d'expérimentation
mais soit parfois se redonner parce que
c'est sensible parce qu'il y a des
contestations donc on dit ça va être
temporaire donc rassurez-vous mais du
coup deux trois fois quatre fois on y
revient nous on avait aussi un peu en
tête au SGG de se dire que en au sein du
gouvernement mais pourquoi pas aussi en
partageant le débat de se poser deux
trois ans après l'application pour se
dire alors même que la loi elle est
pérenne mais est-ce que finalement
est-ce que c'est alors c'est
l'évaluation expose aussi mais où on en
est est-ce que c'est le moment de
relégiférer plutôt que de s'obliger à
religérer avec une scène cette pause et
puis la judiciairement est favorable aux
renforcement de ses études explosent
donc enfin l'évaluation expost oui bien
sûr le gouvernement considère que c'est
une des dimensions qu'il faut qu'il faut
étudier avec l'idée qu'il peut y avoir
plusieurs acteurs susceptibles de
participer à cette à cette évaluation
bien sûr et d'ailleurs on avait un
instauré dans les études d'impact le
choix de plusieurs indicateurs associés
de loi pour être capable à posteriori
d'y revenir du coup je vais je crois que
je vais merci de parler merci beaucoup
ce sera le mot de la fin pour cette
deuxième table ronde puisque nous
accueillons Gérard Larcher président du
Sénat et Christophe bechut ministre
chargé de la transition écologique et de
la cohésion des territoires pour la
séance de clôture de cette matinée qui
va être marquée par un discours du
ministre le discours de clôture du
président Larcher et la signature de la
fameuse charte d'engagement entre le
gouvernement et le Sénat voilà
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président du Sénat vous dire
le plaisir que nous avons à vous
accueillir ici l'intérêt de cette
matinée que nous avons partagé d'une
manière très concertée tous les acteurs
étaient là de la production de l'examen
de la pression
de la norme et je crois qu'il y a
au-delà du discours
on voit ce diagnostic partagé l'envie
d'avancer que vous nous permettrez de
réaliser tout à l'heure grâce à la
charte d'engagement je crois que
monsieur le Président du Sénat vous ne
cessez de le dire et j'ai entendu deux
fois de la part du secrétariat général
du gouvernement et de monsieur le
président adjoint de la section
d'administration du Conseil d'État ce
mot ayant la culture du résultat
l'enjeu est celui de l'efficacité de
l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre ici au Sénat nous rajoutons
toujours
jusqu'au jusqu'au dernier habitant et
nous savons d'une manière grave
qu'aujourd'hui au-delà du délitement de
la confiance entre les citoyens et ceux
et celles dont nous ont partis qui sont
comptables de l'action publique
aujourd'hui se rajoute une fragilité de
l'engagement citoyen je rappelais tout à
l'heure que depuis mars 2020 930 maires
ont démissionné c'est un chiffre qui bat
un record plutôt tragique je n'ai pas le
chiffre du nombre de conseillers
municipaux mais je suis sûr qu'on l'aura
bientôt mais il est pléthorique et je
crois que
une des raisons de ces démissions c'est
que les élus très souvent constatent que
la norme elle produit de l'impossible à
faire et elle produit du surcoût donc je
crois que le temps est à la rigueur et à
la vertu et en tout cas nous sommes
très heureux que votre présence parmi
nous le soutien du président du slam
mais aussi du gouvernement
nous oblige aujourd'hui sans doute à
plus de rigueur et de bonnes conduite et
moins de sortie de route même si de
temps en temps on aura un petit accident
législatif je vous remercie
et je crois que nous devons avoir pardon
la locution de madame la Première
ministre
pour démarrer cette séquence solennelle
et ben non
et le président du Sénat vous vous voyez
la qualité du contrôle ici merci
monsieur le Président vous saviez c'est
pas le moment c'est ça ah j'ai reçu un
message excusez-moi
non je n'ai pas d'oreille bon dites-moi
simplement Marc ce qui se passe
alors il y a pas de vidéo donc alors
c'est monsieur le ministre en live
tu souhaites que je parle de là-bas
je serai tenté de voir dans le fait
qu'après avoir annoncé la première
ministre ça ne soit que le ministre de
la transition écologique qui s'exprime
une sorte d'allégorie par rapport à la
hiérarchie des normes qui que jeunes
filerai pas compte tenu du nombre de
spécialistes et qui sont présents dans
cette salle pour pour vous dire très
simplement le plaisir que j'ai d'être là
l'honneur que j'ai de me retrouver
assis tout près du président Larcher
donc chacun connaît la cohérence et la
constance sur ces sujets
de saluer la secrétaire général du
gouvernement de saluer les sénatrices et
sénateurs qui sont là en commençant par
la présidente de la délégation
sénatoriale au collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
Françoise Gatel le président de
l'Association des maires de France et
puis chacune et chacun d'entre vous ont
son titre son grade ou sa qualité
je vais pas m'apesir sur le constat
chacun connaît
et les formules les plus diverses
permettent d'en rendre compte
il y a
la vision historique qui consiste à
rappeler que du temps des Grecs on
expliquait que nul n'était censé ignorer
la loi puisque elle figurait sur les
murs de l'Agora et le fait de s'amuser à
mesurer la taille du bâtiment qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui pour que la somme
des normes française européenne puissent
tenir dans un endroit où on pourrait le
voir et ensuite le lire ce qui
relèverait évidemment de l'impossibilité
pour une seule journée et une seule
personne
quel que soit la taille de ce qui serait
réalisé il y a la manière
comparative de le faire il y a le fait
d'en évaluer le coût peu importe
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on a
globalement un code général
des collectivités territoriales qui a
triplé de volume je sais pas si c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est amusé à présenter
les codes qui sont peut-être avec les
éditeurs les seuls vrais gagnants de
cette inflation normative d'une manière
objective
et nous avons dépassé le million de mots
2 milliards d'euros c'est l'estimation
globalement de l'inflation normative sur
les cinq dernières années calculées par
la DGCL et avec une règle c'est que plus
vous êtes petit
plus vous avez de mal à suivre cette
inflation normative et donc par
conséquent on crée en particulier pour
les collectivités les plus petites de ce
pays pour un certain nombre d'acteurs de
petites tailles une sorte de dégradation
de leur capacité à agir ou de leur
compétitivité la simplification est donc
à la fois un combat essentiel
pour que la puissance publique préserve
une capacité à agir et que son action
est du sens
et dans le même temps elle est un
impératif au vu des bouleversements
profonds économiques géopolitique
écologique bien sûr que nous traversons
il est d'usage pour chaque problème de
se demander qui en est le responsable je
veux dire que l'inflation des normes à
plusieurs paires
et que dans ce domaine
nous avons
une difficulté qui est devenue
systémique dans lequel il serait trop
simple d'aller identifier un responsable
et de considérer qu'en se débarrassant
de ce responsable on s'est
débarrasserait du problème je veux
saluer la qualité du rapport de
Françoise Gatel et de Rémi Pointreau du
mois de janvier qui montre que tous les
acteurs alimentent cette fabrique de la
norme que le législateur n'est pas en
reste
et que parfois cette multiplication des
normes elle peut répondre à un objectif
légitime de différenciation
pour tenir compte des réalités mais
parfois sous couvert de différenciation
on finit par aller produire de la norme
qui ajoute de la complexité de manière
très forte
depuis 2017
le président de la République a souhaité
que il y ait une lutte contre le pot
excessif de la norme avec un engagement
qui avait été valorisé qui était le deux
pour un du Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe en juillet 2017 à chaque fois
qu'il y a un nouveau texte il faut en
supprimer deux
il y a eu des réussites
avec un nombre de décret autonomes qui a
été divisé par 10
il y a eu une diminution objective du
nombre de circulaire qui est aussi ont
baissé pendant la période et il y a les
promesses de la loi 3DS qui ouvre dans
un certain nombre de champs des
perspectives réelles
pour avancer mais ça c'est la moitié
pleine du verre
ou plus exactement la moitié vide qu'on
s'efforce de ne pas remplir pour ne pas
ajouter de la normale
il faut bien concevoir qu'à côté de ça
non seulement beaucoup restent à faire
aussi bien en matière de flux mais
surtout en matière de gisement de
simplification et de stock
j'ai commencé ma journée par un billet
d'humeur écrit par le maire de Cannes
que vous connaissez peut-être qui
s'appelle David Lisnard et qui a
quelques jours de la présentation du
plan haut du gouvernement dans un
contexte de sécheresse hivernale qu'il y
a peu de précédents expliquait que il
avait eu l'idée de réutiliser les eaux
usées de sa station d'assainissement
dans laquelle il avait investi beaucoup
d'argent qu'on lui avait dit que c'était
une super idée et qu'à force de normes
et d'injonctions contradictoires de la
part des différents ministères il
attendait encore et que donc il misait
beaucoup sur le décret que j'aurais
l'occasion de signer dans quelques jours
donc il appelait quand même de ses vœux
une inflation normative limitée mais
pour permettre de régler
un certain nombre de problèmes et je
reviens à mon sujet
on l'espèce c'est bien la succession des
principes de précautions et des normes
pour aller expliquer tout ce qui n'est
pas possible qui fait que alors qu'on a
une bonne idée qui est mise en oeuvre
ailleurs il y a 50 obstacles juridiques
qui s'y opposent et des quantités de
bonnes raisons ensuite de chacun au
titre de son principe de précaution de
son ministère ou de l'endroit où il voit
les choses de le faire nous avons donc
une nécessité démocratique
mais également politique en termes de
responsabilité à faire en sorte que la
loi s'applique plus rapidement plus
efficacement et en étant plus lisible
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
c'est dans cet esprit que je suis venu
signer cette charte qui vient marquer
une nouvelle étape pragmatique dans
notre lutte commune contre les
simplification pragmatique parce qu'elle
n'est pas seulement une déclaration
d'intention elle réfléchit à droit
existant on dit pas qu'il faudra une
nouvelle réforme on expliqueera pas on
n'explique pas qu'il faut modifier la
Constitution on se penche sur les
pesanteurs
actuels quotidiennes
pragmatique parce qu'on n'invente pas un
nouveau machin on s'appuie sur le
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
et je le dis là aussi avec force je
pense que cette création en 2013 elle a
eu beaucoup de sens mais que contre crée
une instance c'est mieux de s'inspirer
de ses avis et pas seulement qu'elle
travaille à côté de ceux qui produisent
la norme et qu'on a dans ce domaine des
marges d'amélioration comme je vais le
dire
sharp pragmatique enfin parce qu'elle
reconnaît
et qu'elle conforte le Sénat comme étant
la Vigile nos territoires
en assumant de signer cette charte entre
le gouvernement et la chambre haute on
se planche tout de suite sur la volonté
d'obtenir des résultats
d'obtenir des effets concrets avec
notamment la promotion des
expérimentations locales des clauses de
examen et même à titre expérimental des
clauses guillotines pour reprendre une
expression que Françoise Gatel
affectionne je parle pas de la
guillotine je parle de la clause
guillotine madame la Présidente bien
entendu je veux très simplement vous
dire que je suis convaincu que d'autres
acteurs de fabrique de la norme je n'en
doute pas viendront adjoindre à cette
charte et je pense en particulier au
Conseil d'État dont je salue avec
respect les membres qui sont présents
[Applaudissements]
le président du Sénat
monsieur le ministre chers Christophe
bichu madame la présidente de la
délégation collectivité territoriale
chers Françoise Gatel monsieur le
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat monsieur le Premier Vice-Président
chargé de la simplification de la
délégation collectivité territoriale
chère Rémi quattrot je voudrais saluer
le représentant du Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes Arnaud Bazin il
a dû nous quitter une la glisser à
l'oreille mais je voulais saluer son
travail et sa présence mes chers
collègues
sénateurs monsieur le Président de
l'Association des maires de France et
président d'intercommunalité nous allons
nous retrouver d'ailleurs samedi encore
dans un département
au coeur du pays dans le Loiret et puis
je voulais saluer les représentants des
associations d'élus les maires ici
présents madame la secrétaire général du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs
membres du conseil résultats professeur
et les étudiants que je vois ici
nombreux et que nous accueillons avec
beaucoup de plaisir oui je suis heureux
de me retrouver parmi vous aujourd'hui
sur une thématique aussi importante pour
les élus locaux et je vois d'ailleurs
qu'ils compris du ministre l'empreinte
du Sénat est forte et oui
l'empreinte du Sénat est forte parce que
nous sommes bien constitutionnellement
cette chambre représentant des
collectivités territoriales chers David
Lisnard mais aussi un lieu où on se pose
des questions avec pragmatisme c'est
d'ailleurs ce pragmatisme l'intérêt
national qui va conduire ce matin n'a
pas d'avoir pu être au lancement de
votre matinée l'actualité parlementaire
m'a donné quelques occupations à
présider une séance ce matin à l'issue
d'une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive
je sais que le Sénat était très bien
représenté par Françoise Gatel à
l'origine de ses états généraux avec son
premier vice-président Rémi pointron une
rencontre au fond qui s'inscrit dans un
long travail mené par le Sénat et tout
particulièrement par notre délégation
collectivités territoriale en lien
d'ailleurs avec l'Association des maires
de France mais aussi avec le Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes ce qui
me permet de saluer vous l'avez eu par
vidéo en lui souhaitant le meilleur à
Lambert
ainsi le rapport sur les normes
applicable aux collectivités
territoriales je cite face à l'addiction
aux ont une thérapie de choc
c'était le 26 janvier dernier et vous en
avez largement débattu ce matin au fond
c'est aussi le fruit d'un important
travail de concertation une manière
d'ailleurs de j'allais dire de
travailler de la délégation
l'objectif
est simple
proposer des mesures concrètes et
j'insiste sur le mot concret et je sais
que le président de la commission des
lois ainsi sur cette dimension concrète
en vue de limiter cette inflation
normative et freinée on en parle depuis
longtemps j'ai appartenu à deux
gouvernements qui s'étaient engagés à un
moratoire mais sans doute la définition
du mot moratoire
était quelque peu différente de celle
que l'Académie en donne parce que
derrière le moratoire il y en avait
toujours plus
et j'assume
en effet
il n'est pas un déplacement que je fais
que j'allais dire que nous faisons
ensemble parfois chers président de la
MF où nous nous rencontrons où les élus
locaux ne nous parlent pas de ce carcan
normatif
je pense au droit de l'urbanisme
Christophe
[Musique]
un très bel empilement et sans doute par
pudeur vous me l'avez retirez mais je
dois dire que si je prends le seul code
de l'urbanisme
le nombre de mots en disant
a augmenté de 40% dans le code de
l'urbanisme aujourd'hui la complexité du
droit est telle que la plupart des mers
sont obligés de faire appel à des
cabinets extérieurs pour rédiger leur
document d'urbanisme
et ce d'ailleurs sous les injonctions
des services de l'État ils ont perdu le
pouvoir d'agir et c'est pour moi une
vraie préoccupation parce que
pardonnez-moi je le dis devant un membre
éminent du Conseil d'État le président
adjoint de la section de
l'administration car en plus une
expérience d'élus entre l'époque nous
étions ensemble élus
et aujourd'hui cette complexité là rend
quasiment impossible à pouvoir pourtant
fondamental qui nous a été donné par les
textes portant décentralisation c'est à
dire le pouvoir de Gir de rédiger bien
sûr avec le soutien dans un dialogue
avec les services de l'État avec les
autres collectivités territoriales mais
c'est un vrai sujet et je dois vous dire
puisque nous avons mis en place un
groupe de travail pour travailler sur
décentralisation des concentrations et
différenciation que
au-delà du premier sujet cher monsieur
le rapporteur de ce groupe de travail
qui est en face de moi monsieur buffet
et une des rapporteurs qui nous
accompagnaient il y a bien sûr le sujet
d'autonomie fiscalité financière mais
pardonnez-moi de le dire il faut
retrouver une capacité à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions et de
retrouver quelque part cette capacité à
agir
je ne doute pas
que les interventions des représentants
de l'Association des maires de France
Marie-Claude jarrox se voit avec plaisir
ici le maire de Montceau-les-Mines et je
doute pas mais presque voisin le maire
des Molières qui Elvis président de
l'association
aussi
des mers ruraux et je ne doute pas
Christophe bouillon l'a dit tout à
l'heure alors sous le regard visé la
rédactrice en chef d'actualité juridique
des collectivités territoriales je
voudrais vraiment qu'on puisse aboutir à
quelque chose de concret et qu'on passe
du colloque de la réunion du rapport à
la mise en œuvre concrète
Christophe Béchu la rappeler
le coût pour les collectivités c'est
plus de 2 milliards et demi d'euros
c'est des chiffres qui se recoupent
entre la Commission nationale
d'évaluation des normes et
la direction des collectivités
territoriales
je sens
parfois les mères là c'est pas
simplement le titre du Canard Enchaîné
c'est vraiment ce que nous ressentons au
travers du nombre de démissions
chers David l'islam nous d'évoquions il
y a quelques semaines qui sont
préoccupantes de la part de ses mères
donc
la délégation collectivité territoriale
a proposé de revoir la manière d'aborder
le sujet
au lieu de ne s'intéresser qu'aux
conséquences de l'inflation normative il
me paraît j'ai le souvenir de notre
rencontre dans mon bureau vous avez
décidé de prendre le problème à bras le
corps et de vous positionner en amont
sur la fabrique de la norme c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai retenu
je ne vais pas revenir où vous avez
évoqué ce matin sur les propositions
détaillées à l'occasion de la deuxième
table ronde je sais en plus que le
professeur Olivier Renaud dit
et bien sûr gérer que le Sénat puisse
être chef de fil de la simplification je
le remercie en ce moment on est assez
chef de fil et nous sommes prêts à
assumer ce chef de fila
supplémentaire mais je le dis parce que
au fond c'est dans notre état d'esprit
et de manière totalement transgroupe et
non pas j'allais dire pour un objectif
qui pourrait être jugé politique
sont sous stricto mais c'est un objectif
d'intérêt général du pays
entendu monsieur le ministre que vous
disiez il fallait faire attention à ne
pas compliquer les choses voilà pourquoi
je suis dans la joie après vous avoir
écouté quand après la convention
citoyenne sur le climat nous avons
marqué quelques interrogations monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
d'introduire
promptement et par un prompt renfort
ceci dans la Constitution
ça ne veut pas dire que nous ne pensons
pas que ces sujets monsieur le
ministreuse ne sont pas les sujets
majeurs
majeurs mais méfions-nous mais sur nous
d'ailleurs de faire de la Constitution
sur d'autres sujets le catalogue des
droits sociaux et sociétaux
pardonnez-moi je ne suis pas un
constitutionnaliste aussi brillant qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous mais le
pragmatisme et l'expérience du
vétérinaire que je suis converti au
Sénat depuis un certain temps m'amène à
penser que sur ce sujet le principe de
précaution médicale n'est pas
inutile non plus
tout d'abord
quelques sujets pour conclure
je rejoindrai des propos d'Alain Lambert
je sais qu'il a dit dans sa vidéo parce
que j'ai l'occasion de le voir
il a rappelé que chacun contribué à son
niveau à cette inflation normative
dans une vision théologique catholique
ce qui n'est pas mon cas je vous dirai
attention le péché vient de partout
d'où la nécessité de s'autodiscipliner
comme le rappeler Françoise Gatel et
pour cela la présence de différentes
associations d'élus est importante elle
traduit une volonté collective de
trouver une issue à cette addiction
collective comme le soulignait Alain
Lambert
votre présence ça nous coté monsieur le
ministre et également symbolique
témoigne quelque part que le
gouvernement entendra travailler
différemment monsieur le ministre et
vous l'avez dit il y a un instant
et la charte d'engagement qui va être
signée dans quelques instants va montrer
cette volonté commune d'avancer
c'est pas une fin en soi une charte
parce que on en a déjà signé un certain
nombre de chartes
et parfois ces chartes restent à l'état
de charte
il se veut comme le commencement du
nouvel air ou la réalité du terrain doit
primer sur la tentation permanente de
légiférer trop légiféré sur les giféré
et là il faut aussi qu'on se freine nous
les parlementaires
ou désormais le gouvernement les
parlementaires que nous sommes se
demanderont en fonction des études
d'options proposées semi s'il est
vraiment utile d'adopter tel ou tel
texte de loi qui ne peut pas être la
réponse impulsion quelques jours après
d'un événement futile dramatique arrivé
dans le pays je me méfie des lois de
pulsion et d'ailleurs le Conseil des
Anciens
qui préfigure le futur Sénat veut bien
donner cette mission d'éviter les
pulsions pour être un balancier
stabilisateur des institutions et j'y
reviendrai nous n'avons toujours pas de
véritables études d'impact préalable à
la loi
c'est sans doute me semble-t-il ce qui
nous aurait évité quelques difficultés
monsieur le ministre sur un débat que
vous reprendrez ce soir dans un texte
climat résilience pardonnez-moi de faire
de l'actualité mais
c'est quand même le travail du Sénat ce
soir même encore
cette nécessité de mettre la
simplification au cœur de nos réflexions
me paraît un défi le rouge que nous
sommes donnés dans le travail que nous
menons je l'évoquer il y a un instant
sur la décentralisation et nous nous
devrions publier le rapport monsieur
buffet vous avez pris un engagement à la
fin du printemps ce qui nous situe
autour du 21 juin si les choses ne sont
pas totalement déplacés en tous les cas
à l'objectif du feu de Saint Jean qui
doit être un feu de bonheur d'espérance
et de renouvellement alors notre
objectif est simple redonner au maire de
pouvoir d'agir pour reprendre le thème
de votre dernier congrès monsieur le
Président et voilà je vous propose de
passer à la signature mais cette charge
je le dis publiquement on va la faire
vivre
on va la faire vivre ensemble je vous
propose d'ailleurs avec aussi nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale mais
on va la faire vivre avec les élus
locaux et on va la faire vivre avec vous
monsieur le ministre parce que j'ai
envie que cette signature que nous
fassions en commun ne soit pas
simplement la conclusion mais au
contraire le préambule d'un fosture ou
nous sortons de cette hyper hyper
normalisation de notre vie merci
beaucoup de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
nos états généraux sont maintenant
terminés je voulais vraiment tous vous
remercier
de votre participation remercier
particulièrement les intervenants tous
nos partenaires et vous tous qui était
là et je vous invite à partager
[Musique]
un cocktail déjeunatoire qui nous
permettra de poursuivre nos échanges en
toute liberté